welcome once again
to what we like to refer to as the h3
after dark
despite it being 12 20.
h3 good morning
uh but here we are again without the
morning show
no you know morning shows start at like
5 00 a.m
usually right i'd rather die than being
a morning showhouse i swear to god
i'll go working like salt mine
go do manual labor the morning is
technically after dark
it's been dark the last few hours this
is after the dark
it's daytime it's a daytime show
um i was on time dan is the reason we're
late he was [ __ ]
he was budgeting that's not true i
didn't i came down
there 12 13 i was like here we go boys
dan's fudging with stuff you wanted to
change your sweater you had to get the
sunflower
you were bragging about how good it
looks
b you got like a whole setup look at oh
that's because you're back
you're back though yeah you're not here
in l.a yeah
back home michigan i was like whoa dude
you're like
ready to host your own show back there i
was like i just got the av
maybe he can knows today
how you doing ab you broke you broke
fast right ramadan's over and then it's
over
yes i'm done fasting thanks for watching
feels good thank you you made it all the
way through
oh god is god is
gonna bless your ass hard this year
thank you
is that how it works i don't know uh
hopefully
that's the idea that's the idea well no
it's far
more to you know relate to people who
aren't so fortunate
but oh it's a humbling experience yeah
supposedly
yeah anyway it's kind of like a juice
cleanse
a sin cleanse i'm just kidding i'm just
i'm just being an ignorant
idiot i don't know hey uh thank you
who is uh swanston okay yeah me andy
sponsored us thank you dan
thank you miandi oh man we've got a heck
of a show by the way anyway
uh happy uh jesus happy end of ramadan
or whatever i'm proud of you though you
made it all the way through that's
impressive man what do
people say to each other at the end it's
durham it's uh the id is the
holiday
to you my friend thank you appreciate
you guys
round of applause the man made it
[Applause]
he did it okay
yeah we've oh my goodness you guys we
got okay first of all
bill gates yeah is calling in today as
you guys
calling again yeah he's calling in today
you didn't know that we've been talking
about it all week
i don't have a big deal i'm really
excited you guys all know i'm a huge fan
dan come on be respectful because i just
said i'm a huge fan
yeah you're being ironic you don't i
know
bill listen dad stop it be respectful to
our guests
we love dan anyway whoa
um as you know he has having this uh big
divorce
and he's calling in to discuss that so
we're getting the exclusive mm-hmm
and um
oh man and then zach
this is exciting you know uh craft mayo
put out
a challenge for they're looking for a
new mayo man and so zach made an
application video
james charles is being sued oh no i know
something about that
i'm being sued by the way oh no we're
being sued
i feel like it's my fault though i feel
bad that you're even included in it
go ahead speak your mind all right
you didn't do it you weren't even naked
wait were you even here you weren't even
here and actually i had that i didn't
think about it at first no it was just
me
you weren't even here when i was doing
it yeah you you
you stopped being on the midweek
episodes and about a month later we got
into
the rails baby great that's so true i'm
stopping on the episode they were
getting sued
yeah i didn't even know i wasn't on the
episode
yeah no you weren't there
yeah off the true to true to form off
the rails off the rails onto the wait
that's not true
wasn't it after dark that jake paul
fight was no was it was off the rails
yeah i was off the rails well we
listen we are true to our family i was
surprised
that okay the less i say
go ahead elo that's an ongoing lawsuit
the less they say the better
you were going to say something about
okay
i have a lot to say about them
i want to say so much about them well
get back on the rails ethan
this isn't off the rails this is an off
the road i'll save it
so i wonder if they're suing an episode
on off the rails is it
am i technically in the lawsuit i guess
we don't even know yet well they're
suing our company so
which they haven't even but that's
interesting because it's like oh well
and maybe you don't have to be deposed
because that far you're like hey i
wasn't there
right i don't know nothing about nobody
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] was off the rails there was no
conductor
ponderosa yeah excuse me
oh we got a new rice gum left go ahead
zach
that was just from a few days ago
i think and that
yeah and you got this trisha one too
it's in the same vein
oh okay
you know it's not nice to make fun of
someone's laugh but rice comes with pigs
so
[ __ ] him
it's just silly
so let me ask you this i saw this as a
conversation online it kind of confused
me so i'm kind of curious what you guys
think
can you guys unfocus your eyes
yeah yeah can you guys like
right or just like like i'm looking at
the wall
i can make my eyes go out of focus
anytime i want
yeah me too anyone are you guys i could
do that yeah
zach yeah i can do it as well okay so
it's not a [ __ ] debate
what's the debate well there was like
they're like you kind of focus your eyes
like somebody was like what and it
turned into this whole thing about
you know how we ian you didn't answer i
bet your ass can't unfocus can they
i mean every time you cut to me what do
you think's going on
you don't watch the show i mean i do
the focus that's just a little off are
you in your bathrobe
yes are you big are you comfortable
what's going on letting myself go a
little bit
can you unfocus your eyes on the
bathrobe
just there for aesthetics or are you
feeling sick also
i can't stand up zach because i am not
wearing pants
oh my god no wearing pants
no zach or ian is that appropriate
no it's not it's wildly inappropriate i
think he's very unprofessional down here
yeah
don't start damn we got photos of you
walking around with your bare dirty feet
all over our office
the other day good point ian can you
unfocus your eyes
yes you can okay so yeah it's a total
[ __ ] thing so
let me erase this from my document thank
you there's no such thing as a
coincidence
you know there's no there's no such
thing as coincidence i can unsquin
i can put my eyes out of focus and the
fact that you all can too means there's
no such thing as a coincidence oh you're
zoomed on me
you see that sometimes i do it when i
draw i'll try to like
zoom out on focus so that i see the
exaggerated version
i know some people can't do it because
you remember those like magic eye
puzzles where it's like crazy and a lot
of people say they can't
do those like you just focus right but i
know
a lot of people are unable to do it so
we're just all really talented there's
no such thing as the coincidence well i
thought it was one of these things where
it's like oh i wipe from the front i
wipe from the back and they're like what
you wait from the back oh my god you
you know it's like but it's not like
that so it's literally if i could go
back and erase this whole conversation i
would
kill button you want to start over yeah
just hit the kizzle glitch
it's rewind time yeah we got some more
talk
we got some more top of shell things i
thought this was pretty funny
a little cross promotion with a joke
new color block you guys know the color
block hoodie on teddyfresh.com
has been out of stock for a while that's
because we have been re-engineering
remastering remodeling perfecting
this is coming out oh it doesn't have
the date but it's coming out next
thursday
all these colors anyway i made this
funny tick tock to celebrate
this is what james charles does when he
sees the new teddy press
my sisters
[Laughter]
um okay some of you newer viewers may
not know
of that we had this obsession with um
scooter videos
we pretty much exhausted the whole
internet of every funny scooter video oh
[ __ ] i don't show already
uh but a new ones came across my desk
that i thought was worth sharing for
i muted it already i thought it was it
was a
it was really funny man there's so many
good scooter accident videos out there
oh my god
these people on scooters i'm not gonna
make sweeping generalizations about
scooter people i'm sure there's fine
people on both sides
careful in the words of trump let's find
people
listen there's fine people on scooters
there's fine people off scooters
but there i found that there's just a
reckless endangerment for life
from some people some people in the
scooter community
i think it's because they already lost
everything
and so i'm coming i've got nothing to
lose
rebellious scooter movement right yeah
them against the world
well here's this one um
[ __ ] awesome
[Music]
and i think they don't and you know they
don't really know how to operate on this
there's not very safe because you like a
weapon
yeah you're putting like old disabled
handicapped whatever people on these
kind of
like serious machines to help their
mobility but
i mean that checkout counter looks
massive like that's really heavy and it
moves it aside like
no problem bro he pops a wheelie on that
[ __ ]
and he never hits the bricks he's just
he's like this is it bro
popping a wheelie this is how i go out
mobility
that's awesome nobody was hurt luckily
but
that woman could have easily just been
wiped out oh someone did get wiped out
wait let me see
oh the woman in the blue kind of gets
she disappears
wait wait where did she go she got
ethered wait there's a woman in the blue
jacket
oh she she's behind that you fell on the
ground there
wow it looked like she just got
swallowed up no
man there's so many great scooter vids
though out there
unbelievable stuff
ricegum loves it
um oh people should we explain why we're
doing it on thursday or who cares
we're just taking a long weekend yeah
yeah that's why we're doing it
well we're doing a big move this weekend
right is
taking we are moving some of us are
going on vacation and some of us
are working hard yeah we won't say who's
doing what
let's not say who's who thank you dan
yeah
uh so next week
whatever happened with do we confirm
with bella porch is that next week
no it if it it won't be next week okay
regardless
it might be we're going to do our first
interview back in the new office with
bella porche
yeah she's actually you know we had
dinner with her
you guys probably you guys must know her
she's super [ __ ] famous but
like she's like the biggest tick tocker
right one of them she has the biggest
tick tock
on tick-tock wait she has the most
followers i thought that was
no no she has the most ticket
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is her you guys
know her
she came over to our house we had dinner
it was really she's a really interesting
person her story is
fascinating like literally it really is
fascinating
and fascinating fascinating and so
um i think it will be a really great
uh interviewing episode so look forward
to that
coming soon just watching my algorithms
get crushed
yeah yo
okay also kind of at the top of the show
here
this is something that we've been
waiting
it's kind of crazy since may 22
of 2017 that's four years
almost to the almost of the day yeah
pretty close four years
this was teased on a gofundme have you
ever felt uncomfortable
okay wait so let me see public places
this was teased on a
kickstarter
and we thought it was so dumb
we made a whole video about it we
reacted to it and then i made my own
dumb invention called the peep and creep
which is like uh
oh my god you remember the peeping creep
yeah i have like vr gog
what was th i don't even remember the
people it was like vr goggles
i never remember what was that is that
you can creep on out of people but they
don't see your eyes
right oh so you can go to the beach and
look at girls in bikinis but they can't
tell
that you're looking at them so i was
and yeah it was really weird because
i could actually see everything because
it just had like a phone on the front
this was bad if people don't know what
the hell
kind of videos we used to do this is it
oh yeah yeah
yeah i kept trying to cut these ladies
off fun though
anyway so you know i know right
yeah so here's the video anyway the
point is these guys
put this up the hush me
four years ago we finally got it today
we actually got the hush me let me play
you their trailer
have you ever felt uncomfortable when
speaking over the phone in public places
or open space i know it's like i've
never heard that accent anywhere in the
world
have you ever felt uncomfortable
[Music]
has getting up from the library and
stepping outside oh no
i have to watch my ass react to this
outside for 30 seconds ever been way too
much of an inconvenience for you
now you can look like a dollar store
batman super villain that never made it
anyway it's like
you put this on to make it private so we
got the hush me
so the idea is that you can talk on the
phone with this thing
on and not and not like interfere with
the
correcting it's for privacy for privacy
so we got the hush me so there's hold on
there's a little power button on the
front you gotta activate it
turn it on bro okay we're all through
you know it's
funny it looks a lot like the gag
thing it looks exactly like that stupid
gag thing we made
i wonder if they ripped us off
so it goes over the head how much was
this stan
uh oh shoot i forget let me i'll look
through 200
yeah it was it was okay so
if you're in a public setting did you
turn it on here i'm gonna put in the
earbuds obviously
so i can hear with privacy i don't i
don't know that it's on yet
so let's say oh i'm at the library
or let's say i'm at the podcast and i'm
like oh [ __ ] i gotta take this really
important call
i don't want ila to hear i deserve
privacy
because it's thursday baby i deserve
privacy
so
what am i doing wrong it doesn't stay on
my head i like this yeah
yeah so as you can tell
that works really well i can't hear you
at all it's super
it's super discreet it doesn't bring any
attention to yourself
and it completely mutes my talking
voices yeah
the audience can't hear you at all
you're not able to hear my conversation
at all
but will you sound okay to the people on
the phone it's suffocating me
do you want to find out up against my
nose i haven't linked to my phone so if
you turn it on we can record and then
we'll play what it sounds like for the
person on the other side
it's on the front actually there's like
a little button right on the front
on the top yeah yeah in the middle give
me a kiss
okay um we just got update from
can you hear me yeah go ahead
so the price ranges between 149 and 189
depending
on the options i don't know if this is
can you
can can the audience hear me they can
definitely yeah
unfortunately it's not really doing the
job but here i just made a recording i'm
going to send it to you on discord and
you can uh
i was wondering if it was a live feed
yeah so
i don't know if we have like the
upgraded version okay here's
here's my audio if you guys want to know
what's the quality of the hush me sound
to the people on the other end here's
what it sounds like
hello oh that was it oh that was me
there should be another one right under
that or did i send the wrong one hold on
no it's super discreet as you can
imagine it's super easy to carry around
with you
you know nobody will notice what the
[ __ ] oh this
latch key's coming undone
here we go hello this is the same one
no but what's interesting is it it's
actually suffocating me do you see what
i'm saying
yeah it's kind of hard to breathe can
you zoom on my face dan
like watch this show decide
maybe it's supposed to go over your nose
i don't know how oh yeah my nose
yeah there's no space
so it'd have to be like this i mean is
it upside down
no no no you got it the right way
there is a valve uh i noticed to allow
at least some air to come in but yeah
it's
it's a little you put it upside down
maybe
no it's no no that's that's right this
will cover my whole nose
yeah and the nose is supposed to go up
oh you're right here's the photo from
there yeah the nose is
like here's the photo
that that guy cannot breathe
anyway as you can tell this is
basically going to take off i if you
could buy stock and hush me i would be
all over that you have me all in here
you
which is really impressive
yeah go ahead and talk that's just you
talking again dan
no no wait keep playing i know but it's
funny
it picks up plans yeah it picks up you
talking
i can't hear anything it works
it worked that's what the person on the
other side's supposed to be hearing
though
okay so you're saying the person on the
other side
so they successfully make it reverse
yeah the other person can't hear you but
everyone around you can
yeah go ahead okay they're almost there
they just need to reverse technology now
the engineer's like oh i totally
misunderstood
so lost in translation this is the hush
me
at after four years of long waiting
congratulations to the developers
you know i feel bad oh and there's also
it comes with a screw
this is a magnet for some reason and it
has a screw on it
can you zoom on that dan lift it up
close in front of your face so oh yeah
right yeah there was just a random screw
in it when we took it out of the thing
for some reason i don't really know what
that was a little extra bonus there from
hush me
i think will i am will be all over this
dude i'm surprised william didn't think
of this first here you
he can't breathe his nostrils are
entirely covered
look at this there's no your nose is too
big
right good point yeah it's it it's
ethan's fault
right thank you though
i love this product it's one of my favs
all right let's talk about some serious
bro let's talk about triller and jake
paul
i'm not going all in yet but there are
some hot memes that we can look at
for example did you know triller the big
scary media company that's threatening
to sue everybody
if they don't give them 4.99
and all their personal information 49.
yeah 49.99 and admit and
and all their personal information and
their threat
oh what is this it was oh wait explain
this it was removed oh whoa
there's more layers to this wait what it
got removed by the reddit admins yeah
didn't we see that
because the trailer went to we've we
discovered that triller must have gone
to reddit whoa and complain to them to
remove it
they're anti-evil operations but wait
where's the actual
dm yeah i'll send a copy of it okay
thank you
[Music]
yeah it was with the guys kissing what
i can't believe they did that no dude
triller is like
super shady super shameless
so the story goes someone posted this
thank you a.b
this is a dm allegedly i mean it looks
legit
where they're shake there's literally
people on the trailer
instagram page threatening people in the
dms
look at this you made multiple comments
that night implying that you are
watching the paul versus astrid fight
illegally
please note if you do not pay the 50 fee
by june 1st we will have to take legal
action
so they're trying to pursue every single
person that watched
every person got your hat
by the way this crack legal team
don't they have a company to run i yeah
there's a good question although
apparently i don't know how many people
are running the company since it's just
[ __ ] going underwater and it's
actually just a desperate
[ __ ] tick tick-tock rip-off oh man oh
man
so allegedly i don't you know you never
know if these are real or not but
it looks real i'd like to believe it's
real
and it was removed from reddit which is
kind of telling isn't it
maybe okay we'll look into that but so
this guy responds
so you guys are going to sue me over
instagram dms low
please get in contact with one of your
legal associates we will provide them
with instructions on how to pay the fee
bruh like everyone's got a legal team
yeah
well they're just trying to be scary
by the way i this is not my legal advice
but i've been watching this one
lawyer who's doing a summary of the
triller case
and she's like if i was your lawyer i
would definitely
not advise anybody to go to that website
and pay that fine
yeah and put in your info because you're
just being like here's where to find me
here's the crime i did so it's
definitely
listen i i'm not a lawyer that's not
legal advice but i did hear
a lawyer on youtube say definitely don't
do that
i don't know
right jake paul wants that jake paul
gets a cut of each 49.99
oh man he's the person said i have proof
i paid for it if you want
please provide me with a picture of the
activation code
and he sent his two dudes uh having
mick kissing that is not i think that
that's proof of purchase as far as i'm
concerned i'm gonna try sending that to
um
to trailer yeah your honor i submit
for the consideration two men kissing
as proof of birth
[Laughter]
i love how passionate they're kissing
too like you know that
swayed them because they're like this is
it this is good
so anyway someone posted this
and then what happened next
is that it was removed okay
by reddit's anti-evil operation team
what is that okay
exactly good question so when you look
into what is
reddit's anti-evil operation team
superhero team
it gives you an insight and a clue
as to why this post was removed
okay
um can someone you find it i read a
an official explanation i
am not ready to research this live
i'm looking into operations didn't dan
didn't we talk about this didn't you
what amazing i'm finding out about this
is
really i just want to go through this
whole conversation with you about this
uh somebody else some other dan
maybe it was ian one of you guys i'd
talk to about [ __ ] come on
i didn't dream this am i losing my mind
here
i loosely remember you having this
conversation i just don't know who it
was with i think it was dan
i'm trying to think all right well
somebody get me info because so
anyway what's interesting about reddit's
anti-evil
yeah is this is when companies
and individuals send legal complaints to
reddit
about certain posts and then reddit acts
upon those
so it stands to reason that
triller because this post got had like a
lot of
why is it called anti-evil i think it's
like
literally epic meme it's the epic meme
reddit
stuff you know but it's act but it's
it's it's actually such propaganda
because the truth is is that they're
acting on behalf of huge media companies
to remove
posts um
but this post had like 50 000 likes on
reddit it was going like mega viral
and so this stands to theorize
that triller sent reddit a legal
notification
being like oh you don't have
authorization to show our private dms
so they're sensitive little baby [ __ ]
who want to sue and scare everyone
in your opinion oh i can say they're
scared little baby [ __ ]
your honor i i am not a scared little
baby [ __ ]
and i can prove that that was a lie told
in
uh told maliciously
yeah yeah i mean i'm i just google
around it it just seems like it's
when uh the reddit admins get you know
uh
official complaint from somebody for
breaking site-wide rules
whatever that may mean so it was an
actual
reddit admin that's what i find
conspiratorial and interesting about it
interesting thank you so much
thank you take that as a big compliment
um fascinating about the lawsuit
that i'm having with trailer i do i want
to make this clarification
you should explain that they dropped the
first one yeah i think a lot of people
probably last heard that it was dropped
assume that it's over but
yeah okay so here's ethan explaining
the triller shakedown that's what it is
in your opinion
i can say it's a [ __ ] i i could say it's
a shakedown just say
at the end of every sentence okay
minecraft
minecraft yes in a video game in a video
game
they're shaking me down that's my
opinion i can state that that's not
[ __ ] slander i can say it
they're shaking me down i i
we're treading carefully as you can tell
anyway so triller made this huge
complaint
and listed like a shitload of people who
did different things
too like right a jointed
complaint a lawsuit is only allowed when
you can
show or prove reasonably that these
people are conspiring
together because you can't just list a
billion people in a lawsuit and be like
here
[ __ ] you you deal with this so they
listed
a ton of people and me and they alleged
that there was a conspiracy between me
and like spam epic video
epicvideopirate.net
and they alleged that i was charging
people
to to watch the link i mean it was like
from
outer space you know it was such a
poorly conceived
uh low brain complaint
in minecraft correct in my opinion
well anyway the jud well it's not in my
opinion because the judge actually threw
it out
the judge literally had was like this is
garbage this is an illegal jointer you
have to provide
evidence that they're cons they're
they're conspiring
and the the attorney is incompetent i
think or
just
i can't figure out them because like
they're either super incompetent
we don't need to figure it out online i
can fear it's my opinion
i'm theorizing either they're super
um
super incompetent the thing is they're
definitely a cheap law firm so i'm
trying to figure out what that means is
like they
just want to like are they just trying
to get the headline
they because here here's what's
interesting the judge threw out the
lawsuit
and they only refiled against one person
guess who that is
h3h3 the h3 podcast
is that interesting to you guys i
actually didn't know that i assumed that
they were
refiling individually with all of the
yeah no only me or you're the only one
i'm the only person they refiled against
wow pretty interesting right
yeah so they're 100 million dollars of
alleged losses
this incredible [ __ ] uh
conspiracy to defraud them of a hundred
million dollars
all comes down to the h3 podcast
watching a 45 second clip
and fair usage five days after the live
event
and they have suffered catastrophic loss
as a result makes sense makes sense to
me so they've only refiled against us
so they are suing us you know the it was
thrown out by the judge but they are so
they are they refiled against us and
again their attorney so
bad he just copy pasted the same [ __ ]
more or less
like he's still left in lines about like
me
conversion there's like one complaint as
conversion which means i'm like selling
links to the fight which is like he
forgot to erase it
so it's like they put so little effort
into the complaint
it's either like uh
i mean it just seems like a shakedown a
headline trying to scare
scare people to to do the uh
the 499 thing you know gotcha
so uh so you know right now we're in
we're in mediation or not mediation
we're in settlement talks right now to
see if we can work it out
and we're exploring our options but you
know at the end of the day
i do think it's important to be very
clear
that this is a fair use lawsuit
they are attacking our right to cover
their footage it's matt haas 2.0
except we're up against deep pockets and
they're way scarier than mad haas
so like don't get it twisted right this
is literally a fair use lawsuit and they
say it in their
complaint in their lawsuit they say
their damages
is that i rebroadcasted their fight to a
million people and that's why they're
suing us for 50 million dollars
that's a fair use argument that it's
every person that viewed our podcast
they're saying you do not have the right
to critique and criticize
our footage
yeah there i feel like they're using the
terms incorrectly because
rebroadcasting isn't that more about
people who actually just like
um pirate the whole thing and then
like the people actually oh yeah yeah
that's what originally
originally that's what it was it was but
now it's
copyright infringement that's the
technical thing right they're suing us
for
but it's also like this propaganda where
they're trying to make it seem like oh
it's not a fair use thing the guy
stole our fight it's like really 45
seconds
of me talking over the whole clip on a
four-hour event
yeah no that debate of
whether what we did is okay or not
that's a fair use debate
a hundred percent which is what we've
been through already and that's what
that's what i need to make as clear as
possible is that this lawsuit
is an attack on what everybody on
youtube
does that they can just come at you with
this poorly conceived
lawsuit that barely any effort or
research was put into and try to shake
you down
for hundreds of thousands of dollars
that's why we fought the mad house
lawsuit you know matt haas tried to
shake us down for four thousand dollars
and i told him to go [ __ ] himself and we
fought it all the way
right so now i'm like
it's like
it's a tough situation i'll just be
totally honest it's a really tough
situation
and it's very stressful for me because
on one hand i do not want to go through
a lawsuit again
ev i mean ever for any reason it's like
the worst especially
i mean it's obvious it's just horrible
it's invasive it's expensive it's
stressful
it's draining but on the other hand
the one thing that we've always tried to
do in our career is to do the right
thing
and there's one thing that i don't
[ __ ] stand is when people try to [ __ ]
with me
especially when i do the right thing
and that's why i told matt house to go
[ __ ] himself when he asked me for four
thousand dollars in an apology
and that lawsuit ended up making all the
difference in the world for this one
here
what are you looking up either um
[Music]
i don't know people in the chat were
saying that it was dropped again
i'm i'm i'm on it okay that's news to me
yeah i don't think i i'm looking at it
right now too i don't think it was
dropped but there was some
triller did get denied in some motion
that they were doing i don't know and by
the way uh the
youtuber lawyer that you're referring to
her name is emily d baker oh yeah and uh
yeah
and she's really cool thank you for
saying her name yeah
i've been actually watching all of her
videos i even though i like fall i
obviously follow everything there's a
new color black
thing jesus i mean that one i'm not mad
about
is this teddy bear the i don't know why
people do the teddy bear always
it's like i i'm here let me pull that up
is it in the chat yeah
oh it's dreams the youtuber i don't know
let's
tag that because i want to talk about it
later you guys got it he's super popular
yeah is that the minecraft guy yeah
got it so anyway it's like
it's good it's gonna be hell right it's
gonna be hell
it's gonna be [ __ ] hell the lawsuit
i can't emphasize how hellish it's going
to be
but the first time we did it
it was the right thing it has a huge
impact on fair use on youtube as well
and this second time
i mean the whole reason we fought the
first lawsuit is to prevent [ __ ] like
this happening again
this is not different because what they
are arguing is that
by us showing the short clip
on our podcast and talking over it
um they're saying a million people
watched our video
therefore um those people
will not be watching their live event
because they saw it on our podcast
yeah they're saying we diverted that is
a fair use
um conversation that's exactly what our
first lawsuit was about and this one
will be too
the thing is people who watch our
podcast watch it for a different reason
and we provide different context we talk
over it we explain
our point of view we commentary and
criticism parody
the whole thing so it's just i don't get
how they are even so uneducated to go
after the same thing that we've already
been through well because
because but they have deep pockets
they there's a reason they only file
re-file against us
because they want the headline they want
to scare people
and they want to make an example out of
us
and i they think that we're scared and
desperate to settle
that's i that's not the case the case is
i'm being i'm trying to be very
thoughtful and strategic about how i
want to handle this
but um
it's a but i just you guys need to
understand this is 100
a fair use lawsuit
period so us paying them off
what is that sound a bomb it's a thunder
clap
you were laying down the hammer there oh
i did i didn't realize i laid down the
hammer yep
if we settle this this gives
litigious pieces of [ __ ]
media companies the green light to shake
down
anyone they want with some [ __ ]
shoddily research and written complaint
okay you know what i'm saying if we
fight it like we did last time
we strengthen the we strengthen
the case for fair use on youtube
and these big media companies need to
understand that they can't just come
funk with us because i'm not disney you
know what i mean
they expect us just to be like i'm sorry
chiller
you're so scary just take whatever it is
and oh by the way they want me to sign a
um
did i mention that i don't think you can
mention that stuff yet
no well there's also other conditions to
the settlement which i'll probably talk
about later
that are ludicrous that will never
[ __ ] happen in a million years
yup uh that affects everybody right
so you know we're trying to figure out
what's the best possible way to deal
with this
but um
yeah it's pretty crazy it's pretty crazy
that they're going after us though
ironic too because we're like the people
that
already proved that we're willing to
[ __ ]
fall on the sword for the right for fair
use
but okay i guess that's all i'll say
about that for now
we gotta do the ad
oh let's do an ad speaking of having
huge legal fees
me undies is supporting us
hey
listen to that fun summer music summer's
coming
and for so many of us it's the season of
discomfort
i know that my undies ride boy and
that's summer bye
[Music]
not a good situation for me when it's
hot and sweaty
when it's hot out if you could sit
around in your underwear you would
me undies want you to make this summer
of comfort
and i want you to know that if you want
to sit around in your underwear that's
absolutely allowed
you should you should probably ask you
know feel the room
ian's taking up that offer right now
yeah just read the room i'd say
yeah are you in your underwear right are
you in your me undies right now ian
yes thank you i knew you were
by how comfortable you look get
comfortable and express yourself this
summer in the undies and classic and
bold colors
it's fun and adventurous guys
rushing home to change into something
more comfortable as a thing of the past
because guess what
me undies is the most comfortable
underwear ever made it's made from like
this futuristic micro modal
it breathe is that saying that right it
breathes baby
it feels good i'm tired of wearing the
same
hanes 20 pack underwear that i've been
wearing since sixth grade
how what's the longest evolved underwear
you know what i'm saying
definitely a long time you had underwear
that's you all have underwear that's
disintegrating in your underwear drawer
right now
guarantee it get rid of that [ __ ] dude
it's time to upgrade
stay comfy all day and me undies they
got undies
socks bralettes loungewear and more
and you can choose from x dress small to
4xl for our big beautiful friends
with their sustainably soft micro moto
and ultra light breathe fabric
and they've got a great offer for our
listeners for any first time purchase
you get 15 percent off and free shipping
me undies also has their problem free
philosophy
if you're not 100 billion percent
satisfied
you get a refund or an exchange no
caveats no questions
they won't even ask you they'd be like
what i love that
they'd be like i'm sorry you don't why
are you returning the most comfortable
underwear no they don't even ask that
they're like fine give it back
15 off your first order free shipping
go to meundies.com h3 that's me undies
dot com
slash h3 love them
we love our sponsors don't we folks
thank you peace so speaking we we
kind of got sidetracked with this hoodie
thing that i wanted to talk about
yeah we have bill gates lined up don't
we uh we do
and uh we could go to that shortly if
you'd like um i do want to
uh issue a correction uh the uh that
sweater is not
from dream the youtuber it's from dream
the uh
i guess clothing company i've never
heard of dream yeah the dream clothing
company me
you know what i'm just gonna say this
this doesn't bother me i don't think
this is a ripoff
what bothers me is the teddy bear and
the exact
basement too you know it's like i was
like this is the colors are different
you know cool fine why you why do you
gotta have to throw a teddy bear on the
vest
it's like just come on bro it's pretty
blatant
anyway it's different i don't care it's
it's not like a james charles thing
where it's like a carbon copy
yeah doesn't really i just think it's
funny they
use the teddy bear it's like dude come
on what are you doing
but i don't care god bless them
shout out to their families shout out to
their families
um um i also wanted to make fun of jake
paul a little bit
since we're on the topic of trailer
um jake paul as you guys know got
punched in the face by like
was it floyd that punched him or one of
his bodyguards pretty
unclear because his giant scuffle
between a bunch of people
but i'm so cynical about all this stuff
you know what's funny about triller's
lawsuit too it's like do you not want me
to talk about your fights
it's like i talked so much about your
stupid [ __ ] fight
before aft and after do you
not want me to talk about your fight
it's like
what do you want yeah it's like
self-defeating their whole the whole
lawsuit is just moronic
with peace and love i'll be sure our
lawyers and
this is the same case with matt haas too
right it was like we are if anything is
sending you traffic
it's it's like these weird ego plays
it's the same thing
you know like how do you prove losses
anyway if anything they should be paying
me for promoting their [ __ ] dumb ass
fight
you know what i mean uh
anyway jake paul got punched in the face
and cried like a little [ __ ]
i cut your head i got your hat
he's crying such a baby
he also first of all there's nothing
wrong with crying i mean you know i cry
but uh all the time oh i'm an emotional
wreck
but jake paul when he you know again
iron eeler
jake paul who you know i think that the
breadcrumb
the breadcrumb on this lawsuit pretty
clearly
leads which i'll paint for you guys
later
keemstar snitched on us to jake paul
who snitched to trailer that's my theory
obviously i don't know anything for sure
i'll try to prove that to you guys
keemstar of course being the biggest
piece of the world
which i'll get into but here's
uh jake paul crying about his lawsuits
um which is just
ironic considering the circumstance i
have
a uh a phone call like with my lawyers
for one of the lawsuits
and i knew that it was gonna be like a
big
l and like i'm just sitting on the phone
call
for literally like like something i did
not do
like it's it's and it goes back to like
people just like attacking jake paul
and like wanting to see me fail
for literally like nothing like
bro like they're suing me for something
like on god it's just the most [ __ ]
thing
and i literally had to pay them a lot of
[ __ ] money
for no reason and i'm like it just
pisses me
the [ __ ] off and then
[Music]
[Music]
give him a hug bro
[Music]
maybe you could sit on that side with
him
[Music]
yeah your piece of [ __ ] hypocrite
[ __ ] dumbass and by the way
here's what he was sued for he was
crying about
i'm being sued by a company jake paul
has a stake in
jake paul was sued i got your hat
jake paul was sued for let's see oh this
one's actually pretty funny i mean in a
horrible way
jake and his team drove around scaring
unsuspected pedestrians with an
abnormally
loud car horn somebody sued them saying
that they damaged their hearing
[Music]
he's like i literally didn't do that
it's on video
posted it to his own channel here's the
other one that he
the uh the following year jake was sued
by his landlord you remember the team 10
house where he was lighting the pool on
fire and [ __ ] how could anyone forget
right uh the mayor had to make a
statement
remember that yep
so his landlord the owner of that house
sued for 2.5 million in damages to the
rental property
including burn marks in the pool dead
shrubbery and broken cabinets
i didn't do i swear on god
it's just not fair oh god on god bro
yo did you guys he did you you anyway um
i know gotcha oh and then he was sued a
third time
uh remember his song litmus where he
basically brainwashed kids into buying
it was part of his whole
christmas album right he had made like a
lit miss yeah
because it's it's lit
uh he was sued for copyright
infringement
from musicians who he say he stole
their track for litmus
which was from apparently a 2005 tomb
called bad and santa so
it was already a christmas beat that he
stole
um there you have it
so my heart my heart goes deeply out to
jake paul
and uh
i just wish i could give him a hug i
don't know
um but we let's do i've got
yeah we better talk to bill gates since
he's on the phone and then we'll come
back to this whole
breadcrumb trail so bill gates
um just give you a little recap before
we take his call
recently divorced 27 years of marriage
i was like why aft i was like why would
they after
27 years get a divorce unless
so my original theory was like did was
some did someone cheat you know
what do you mean what's so confusing
well it's like if you don't
like they don't want to be together
right but after 27 years and having
three kids it's like
and and also like so much money there
it's like why
they could just could they just work it
out
i'm saying it must something big must
have happened i think to justify
a divorce
i don't know well you just don't one day
be like
listen i'm over it you're over it that
just seems weird to me after 27 years
i mean divorces happen like all the time
i'm surprised that you're surprised
well in this case though well i was
right we do know oh
okay got your hat
dan why don't you tell it because you're
the bill gates enthusiast and you take
you go ahead because this was your
you've been talking about this
go ahead dan i won't take this from you
yeah well long time fans of the show
know that i am a big advocate for bill
gates
and um yeah uh so
an article came out that she actually
started talking to divorce lawyers back
in 2019
um specifically in october of 2019
and what's interesting about that date
is in september of 2019 one month prior
there was sort of a bombshell uh i think
was in the new yorker
uh article by ronan farrow
about a lot of rich and powerful
people's connections to
friend of the show jeffrey epstein
and vin diesel
come on van um
so the timing is a little uh suspicious
and um now yeah there is reporting
coming out not necessarily confirmed
um but the the rumor that is um
being published and not i should make it
clear it's not like tabloid rumors i
think it was the wall street journal
that reported this so you know
large uh media publications
are saying that um that was one of if
not the
primary motivating factor for melinda
filing from divorce
from bill so wow yeah so they um pretty
crazy right
yeah so bill has repeatedly denied a
close association with epstein he says
that he met him once
at a dinner party or something and
that was it but what that reporting
uh indicated is that that's not really
true they actually did do business
together they met in 2013 by the way
which was several years after he had
been convicted
for don't say the word
come on dan you know better yeah
look it up look it up that
on the internet information is st you
could say
um yeah i think most people at this
point
i think most people at this point know
what jeffrey epstein was all about he's
a pro
you could say he's a predator he's a
predator yeah that's
honestly that's putting it lightly right
he deserves
he deserves a lot worse than the
predator title anyways um
he's epstein he gets his own thing yeah
he's kind of on his own
he's got his own thing he ruined salt
you know there's epstein salt i don't
buy that anymore
wait are you kidding me i stopped using
salt
isn't it epson salt oh epson right okay
good the boycott's off
are you kidding me go ahead dan
td mega doodoo
anyways um yeah so without getting
bogged down in the details uh
he did have a longer associate and more
uh
close association to epstein than he had
indicated yeah
uh he donated uh he helped facilitate
some donations
he apparently wandered yeah basically
after nation
right after yeah after epstein got in
trouble um
you know he was a large donator to a lot
of uh
colleges and stuff mit in particular he
had given a ton of money to because he
was all into this weird like gene
editing research and he was like trying
to freeze
just the guy i want editing jeans yeah
he was trying to freeze his sperm
so that because he was like epstein was
yeah he had this weird belief
how is he involved so he was epstein
couldn't
donate money anymore because he got
popped he got blacklisted
and then allegedly bill gates was
laundering donations
he was kind of like helping epstein give
the money which was like
but that's just it's all gonna come you
know when i when i was i'm down trump
i mean well i was kind of like a bill
gates uh i i thought his work was
interesting
like the humanitarian work he was doing
he's up to some weird [ __ ] dude and how
he pledged to give all of his money to
charity when he died which
but and then when i looked into his
epstein connection
i what i learned what i thought i've
learned was like he's like oh i met him
once about some kind of charity or
foundation and uh and
bad vibes and i never talk to him again
according to his wife
now ex-wife melinda our soon-to-be
ex-wife
these [ __ ]
what wait bill also flew on his
jet apparently um he is he
says bill gates reportedly flew on
epstein's private jet
the lolita express i can't speak to that
i
had not heard that from new jer well who
wrote yeah that's
that's not what he called it for the
record yeah yeah that was not the
official title okay you know that's the
uh name
that wasn't written on the side of the
plane yeah the after watching all the
documentaries that came out about
epstein
i can forgive someone for meeting him
once
yeah because they're about rich or
whatever and yeah they're in the same
circles
sure but beyond once yeah there's no way
you don't know what he's up to
it's like his whole life his whole
life's purpose
was just his the stuff that he was doing
yeah it was so bizarre
like there's no way you didn't know what
he was up to
first of all the documentary about him
is really good on netflix i recommend
but
especially someone with like bill gates
who's has so much resources and hope
high profile
i'm assuming that anyone he meets with
or even entertains going into business
with
is vetted to like the nth degree you
know what i mean yeah you don't get a
meeting with bill gates without them
knowing who you are yeah so
it's it's definitely sus um wow as far
as the flight log thing i i don't know
who put that in there
i i'm pretty certain that isn't true
because i i've
when we talked about that scene stuff a
few years ago i looked into the flight
logs and who was on there and there's a
lot of prominent names and
bill gates you said it's not true he did
not fly on the thing
he did not it was going around on the
internet for a while but that's what the
flight loss was
damn you're trying to get me sued by
bill gates
i don't put it in there yeah like i said
i i did i
i was unaware of any connection bill
gates has his own plane i'm pretty sure
yeah
bill gates doesn't need to hit your ride
on anything yeah exactly um
lolita express yeah but regardless the
point being he
he had vehemently downplayed his
connections to epstein and
anyway it creeped out his wife enough to
want to get a divorce right and i guess
his wife had already
expressed that like i don't like that
you're associating with this guy and
he's like okay no problem i won't
and then it came out even has an update
new york times march 2013 mr gates flew
on epstein's gulfstream plane
from teterboro airport in new jersey
to palm beach florida according to a
flight manifest mr
arnold said mr gates who has his own 40
million dollar jet
hadn't been aware it was mr epstein's
plane
he didn't know it was epstein's plane
yeah no
your own plan okay i guess there's some
interesting according to ian who's
a reputable source ian is a legend yeah
ian's not wrong
well anyway listen there's a lot of
questions but like we've got bill gates
on hold
yeah i mean we're asking we can ask him
and have him clear this all up wow i
didn't know
yeah let's talk to bill okay hold on one
second appreciate him standing by i know
he's busy
yeah you know
he's like semi-retired now so maybe he's
you know
let's hear what he's gonna say so give
me one second i'm uh
but this is quite an honor i mean this
is an exclusive i don't think he's
publicly
done any interviews or spoken about the
divorce or anything like that
right uh bill are you on the line do we
have bill
yes i'm here oh oh
oh oh okay first of all bill
thank you for joining us i understand
excited to be on
well thank you though it's likewise now
i understand
there's a lot going on i just want to
ask first of all how are you doing
well i'm i'm i'm okay i'm just a little
um
a little uh depressed and sad about a
lot of the vilification
uh around uh the vaccinations
and then obviously what's going on with
uh
my possible impending divorce
and i just thought i'd reach out to you
because you
have a wonderful platform with a lot of
people who are dating
and having a good time oh wait a minute
dating yeah uh bill
there our audience might be a little
young for you right oh
well that seemed that's okay that's okay
i can handle that
right it's ages are you saying age is
more just a number to you
age is just a binary metric uh of
someone's life it's not necessarily
where they are in their life
right i get it it's all just ones and
o's
well let me ask you this bill to be more
specific would you consider someone that
age
100 to be within a territory or no
well i am looking for someone look i i
mean you know this
i i'm going to be honest with you
because your group of people who listen
to your
show know that um that probably have
been reading and my i'm in
a loveless marriage and it's time
i i want to take the shackles off and
turn my software back into hardware
oh wow really live the last few years of
my life with someone who's
much more attractive and fun oh
so is this so well according to
uh media reports your wife is the one
that's leaving you are you disputing
that
no i i'm not disputing that it's the
only woman i've
excuse me oh i'm sorry it's it's just
it's the only woman who was willing to
marry me and now she's leaving so i'm
kind of back to zero but it's it's okay
i have a lot of money
uh she's gonna get a lot of it but i
feel i can
uh be with someone for these last you
know few decades
that it's much more um much more fun to
be with
melinda was always about charitable
giving and saving people all i've ever
really wanted to do is party
because you can probably tell i'm a
party guy
right when i say party i mean reading
right sure of course um well
uh there's been a lot of concerning the
reports has been that your wife actually
left you
because of your alleged ties with
epstein are you well i i ethan i would
like to say that it's not necessarily
i went to uh mr epstein who i
barely know i was only to his island
23 or 24 times wow that is weight that's
a
wow okay i was just in and out honestly
basically i was just there to ask for
some money
uh because we figured he'd be a
wonderful
uh a panacea to a lot of people who are
philanthropic to help with a lot of the
work that we were doing well i'm
i'm sensing a little bit of bs here uh
mr gates
you were asking epstein for money you're
like the richest man of the
man in the world i mean what i mean to
me that i'm
i'm just i'm not getting a satisfactory
explanation
for why you need to go to that island i
would ethan i would like to point out
that you remind me of my uh wife's
divorce attorney number one and secondly
i would like to say that uh uh i am even
though i'm
one of the richest men in the world i
believe in
opp oh what is that
other people's money oh right i guess
i guess you don't you don't become the
richest by using your own money right
bill
exactly exactly and that's how we built
microsoft to be one of the
greatest corporations in history with
one of the greatest
operating systems what do you think
about
um what do you think about like
are you're not putting microchips in
vaccines here right like i want to ask
you that just straight up
oh we tried but you kept showing up in
the photos they were too obvious we just
couldn't get them small enough
right right okay so they're not so just
to clear the record they're not
in there you try not but if you're yet
we're working as hard as we can to get
them as tiny as possible
probably the next round of vaccines will
have it
oh that's comforting to know yes exactly
wow but i was hoping that maybe your
audience could help me
to get back to uh dating and there's
some
dating sites i'm unaware of so much of
what's going on out there
what dating sites are you on are you are
you on any are you looking i wanted to
ask
your people maybe even you and your
lovely wife who you're
you're having a wonderful relationship
with yeah as opposed to my wife
melinda but uh there's a site called
elite singles
which i thought would be perfect for me
uh
farmers only oh farmers only i know that
site
yeah there's a zusk is that anything
that you would use
zeus i'm not familiar with that um
our time which is for older people then
there's a lesbian one called her
oh lesbian that would double my chances
i don't think i don't think that you i
think a lesbian site's probably
just i mean well seeing as i mean you're
not a lesbian right i don't want to
misgender you or something or no no i
just figured if it's the whole site is
women i'd have a better
chance i see that i don't think that's
the intention
no yeah i think you missed the point
there there's something
uh called a bumble have you heard of
bumble
i have heard of bumble that could work i
think that's perfect for me because i
love tuna
so that might be a wonderful thing you
like tuna
right and then there's christian mingle
oh oh are you looking to meet a
christian woman
not necessarily but there's also satanic
singles
so if i you know i could cover both
bases
you know uh mr gates i want to ask you
there's this famous video i don't know
if you can see my screen can you see my
screen dan
uh no but uh well there's a famous video
of you
drinking uh poo water
yes that's the that's my poop water yeah
you want to tell me a lot of money into
that here let me play for the audience
he has this whole refinery where he is
very raw
sewage the solution we're seeing here
and it generates electricity
it generates potable drinking water so
right how was that poop water i've
always wondered it's
it's it's not just poop it's urine too
all right
thank you for that correct world
electricity it makes incredibly clean
water with just a
hint of salt you know what i mean and
there's not just the regular water
there's chunky too
oh no it's got a pen you know they
it's interesting though a pinch of salt
you know like there's there's certain
labels that do that for they say
a little bit of like uh you know salt
for flavor
right right and we we have that we're
we're taking just tons of poop
and urine and turning it into you're
probably drinking it now and you're not
even aware of it
well oh yeah what you know what you
used my whole life growing up you were
the richest man in the world
straight up bill gates now you've got
you've got people like elon musk you got
jeff bezos
and well jeff and i are friends he told
me he'd be my wingman
if we went out oh right both recently
devoured that funny eye which i think is
going to turn the girls off
yeah who do you think who do you think
would have an easier time picking up
girls you are
or jeff well i think jeff because
he's got that shaved head and he looks
like uh
uh he i think him with a monocle on and
a tuxedo he'd do very very well
i don't see why you can't rock that you
know jeff has been working
out uh far more than i have because i
love my cheeseburgers
and french fries which we're trying to
get to a totally
plant-based uh kind of
because i'm working with the impossible
burger people
okay that's important i i appreciate
that insight
but are you jealous of perhaps of elon
and jeff's
because they're both doing the space
race do you feel left out at all that
you're not like i feel totally left out
i could have easily
come up with a rocket ship or something
like that but i am
this is all melinda's fault by the way
because we're so busy trying to save the
world
and uh climate and all the boring stuff
and these guys
are going up in rockets and they're
making me look like a total
loser right yeah yeah you better step up
that space race stuff
and you better get your story straight
with epstein because i'm a little bit
worried about you because you told us
today
you went to his island 23 times that
just sounds suspicious to me so mr gates
like i said i was in i was out i was in
i was out that's
no that does not sound good mr gabe no
that's uh
my attorney uh about that you know but
we're
we're doing so many wonderful things i'm
investing in so many companies and
you know i was i predicted covid
uh many many years before it happened
really wait i did a ted talk on it
i did a full ted talk you can watch it i
said this was going to be the
the issue and that's why we were so out
front with the vaccines
so you predicted it so okay bill are you
did you invent kovid
did you release kovid i i wouldn't say
invented it but i helped
put it all together oh man that is
not something you want to say well
because otherwise the ted talk would be
worthless
so the ted talk now if you go back and
watch it it has a little bit of a
difference makes perfect sense it makes
sense
i'm still pissed about not having
rockets to go to mars
oh man bill you've got a lot of
messaging to work on with your lawyer
i'll say that
absolutely absolutely and i i i want to
clear up
one other thing and i don't know are you
are you going to be asking me about that
other thing i told your producer
not to ask me about uh no
because i don't know what what is that
well what do you want to tell me about
it i mean
the whole thing of the foreskins that
we've been taking oh
you know you've been harvesting
foreskins yeah i i'm curious about that
bill um what what are you doing with all
those foreskins
basically what we're doing is extracting
the
stem cells from the foreskins
and then we're done with the foreskins i
make wallets out of them
oh no bill bill
where do you get these foreskins by the
way this is a real story this isn't a
gag right
uh yeah no he's uh he's been on a
uh an easter egg easter egg hunt kind of
situation well where are you getting
foreskin in this world
uh well actually biso bezos has them
on amazon now but directly
uh when we're over in some of the
countries we're working
in oh man i i would name the country but
then i don't want every other
billionaire rushing there to
right right right wow
man yeah you don't want the competition
so we're we've got bill gates here
drowning i can see the photo with uh
elon musk and uh uh
what's her name gizelle i think you know
her name
yeah i'm pretty sure you know her name i
can't remember she looks very familiar
though
oh do you yeah have you met gisele uh
just chisel jizzle lane maxwell
i i i i would be remiss if i said i
didn't
let me ask you one more thing do you
have any idea
how epstein managed
to un-alive himself do you have any
involvement in that now that we know
you're
no i have nothing to do with that
neither does bezos
neither does bloomberg neither does
clinton
all of us got together and pretty much
decided we had nothing to do with it all
right
okay that checks out yeah
listen bill good luck with all the baby
foreskin i'm sure you're working on
something really exciting well that's my
next big thing
is baby forest and get out in space
there will you you're embarrassing
yourself absolutely as soon as i divorce
uh whatever her name is melinda then
it's going to be
party time for bill gates
well st i just stay away from known
predators all right and you'll be good
absolutely and don't believe what you're
gonna read online in these next few
weeks
okay all right i'm getting ready to not
believe it
thank you bill gates for calling into
the show what a what a
honor what an honor thank you bill
good luck best of luck to you bill gates
what an exclusive
wow yeah there's a lot of a lot to
unpack there
um 23 visits to the island
that's kind of a big revelation i mean
it takes
usually a couple dozen visits to kind of
get an impression of somewhere zach
are you where are you speaking of
epstein's island look at that
has backgrounds of the beach yes uh
chill day today
[Music]
that's actually a true story about the
baby foreskin though isn't it
uh evidently so he actually
is collecting foreskin interesting
can you get a headline i actually want
to know there's a lot you can do with
baby foreskin dude i mean
right it's a valuable commodity i just
want to know if he's really doing it
though
there's a facebook group on it okay well
then it's true then
[Laughter]
uh for the youtube raiders watching this
um that was all parody
including parody parody parody and
minecraft
parody in minecraft so back up to my
conspiracy
i am very surprised by the whole story
though i didn't know
well his wife kind of like oh you know
was another interesting
wrinkle is that like weeks before
she filed for divorce bill sent her like
uh
two billion dollars in microsoft stock
like he was trying to like
pay her off because this whole
revelation about the epstein connection
is pretty
groundbreaking yeah because when i read
about it i was like ah he
didn't have any like what he didn't even
you know what i mean but his own wife is
like nah this guy
is way too close
there's no such thing as a coincidence
what it's like bill said in the call
he's like me clinton
trump bloomberg the royal family
bloomberg all got together and decided
that they had nothing to do with it so
oh here it is oh wow so here this
happened bill gates transferred 2.4
billion in stocks to assume to be
ex-wife melinda 600 million more than
what
was initially reported on the day of one
of the wealthiest couple's announcement
they were splitting
so what do you make of that weird yeah
super weird there's no such thing as the
coin
that's right oh man super weird
hey um joe biden do you think i should
get pizza tonight
i don't think he's on the call no but
joe oh i
probably best i don't oh oh deny what
about the economy won't that boost the
economy joe biden
[Laughter]
sleepy joe provided me
okay i i need the whole sound bite here
this is my favorite soundbite of the i'm
just gonna pull it up on youtube this is
the best
sound bite of the decade joe biden
whispering it grows the economy
i don't think you've seen the whole
thing yet either no i haven't
guess what it crossed the economy
these are all really long here someone
just find me the short one because these
are all super long
so anyway before bill gates rudely
interrupted
we were talking about uh
um guess what
yeah it goes the economy there
benefits everybody hurts nobody
okay now let me ask you again
joe biden
what do you think about ordering pizza
tonight
you see that's pretty funny
nobody right and
bro you don't [ __ ] hate joe biden is
the man dude
across the economy across the economy
[Laughter]
that guy gets killed
you know what i want to do because i
have to pee come on we have this
um
okay should i play the mayo
ad i don't want to miss it though i just
have to pee really bad
maybe i should just give ila a moment to
shine
eli you shine shining how do i i'll be
back in
literally 30 seconds what a big pimps
ask joe biden about things that will
stimulate the economy
um joe biden should i
buy a new bag
right should ethan and ela buy me the
zero gravity uh
joke should even anila buy me the zero
gravity uh
gyro chair
that's right thank you joe benefits
everybody
you guys have donations uh ian that you
guys saved
that we should read or no not really
it's just they don't show anymore
uh i saw one that said
4.99 can you all please not have
bella thorne on your show well it's horn
she's harmed so many sex workers and she
is actually
gross that's not the girl we're talking
about
we're never going to have bella thorne
on the show but um
bella porch different bella
and there's too many bellas we've dealt
with bill delphine i guess that's bell
not bella
she her and i kind of connected in the
dms
and you slid into bella's dms huh ela
she's really nice
and i think that i don't know i feel
like she gets
no i feel like she kind of gets
like i don't know i don't know if it's
just like
maybe i just shouldn't look at comments
ever but sometimes i see people kind of
being mean to her and
um i feel like it's going to be
interesting for them to
hear her story and hear more about her
because she really is interesting
i really don't know very much about her
at all uh other than the fact that she's
a huge
she's huge on tick tock and everything
but um
yeah and you guys said that so i'm kind
of i'm curious for the interview as well
which uh assuming we're able to work out
the logistics and she comes on
um her first interview so
kind of a big deal she's never done one
before so
um okay someone said waiting on ela
pronunciation so
how to pronounce my name
the thing is that i
before i find out on goddamn youtube
that's how we've been finding all the
advantages right
i didn't even know i was being sued
until i saw that press release everyone
knows everything before we do it
well usually you get served we didn't
get started well because their lawyers
are such
[ __ ] and competent they don't they
go on the complaint it says h3 puck has
an unknown business entity
they don't know anything about us they
don't know the name or business they
don't know where we do business how are
they going to serve us when they haven't
done the bare minimum
to even do that research here's this is
just came out from
emily baker here here i'll just pull it
up here [ __ ] me
okay this is big news let me just finish
i'm sorry this is just big news i got
excited go ahead
is joe biden approving i was gonna talk
about the my name pronunciation so
because it's in hebrew
it's like in english i don't know you
can say it however you want really
in hebrew you say ilan
so go ahead and translate it however
makes sense
so that the emphasis is on the the
second uh
syllable right but because like i always
say ela
oh well i americanized it and he said
like hilar
because ela i say
i like silent age yeah yeah don't use
the i spell it like
i l a but i see the way i write it is
h-i-l-a
just because that was what i thought
made sense the thing is there's the
sound in hebrew that doesn't really oh
my god
did i even can i get one of those too oh
my god legend
oh i thought maybe once for you thank
you so much
oh my goodness elizabeth if you got some
more yeah i'm sure i'll take some
elizabeth just brought us coffee it was
the best moment of my day
oh i yeah why because this one says it's
darker oh
um you know i've been wondering lately
did i not spell my name correct
no it's fine it's just is that how you
would spell it though h-i-l-a
i think that's how you spell that's how
people spell it
no i like the way it's spelled it's just
that in
hebrew there's this pronunciation
that doesn't really exist in english the
like
it's like the h i sound in your name is
is something that you don't see in
english
hilah hilah but it's like hilar it's
like the inflection too
right the reflection being on the on the
back half of the
name yeah he's not unusual for like he
loves i feel like
yeah but that sounds like so odd i feel
like i'm shouting your name like you're
like
it's like you're speaking here but the
thing is that when you you're speaking
english you can't say like that it's
like it's like
right it doesn't fit the rhythm of the
language it's like saying homos or
hummus you know
right like hey i'm gonna eat homos it
just doesn't go in one sentence
yeah when it sticks out yeah so i get
used to the way you say it
but i really don't mind if people say it
like
another way because i mean it's not like
one way is incorrect
some people call you gila and i think
that's totally fine too yeah
it's not like incorrect
okay this is just breaking news this was
just posted an hour ago
by emily d baker who's been following
and reading all the complaints that i've
been following
so this is news to me this is breaking
[ __ ] news
okay so
uh the title is triller motion denied
i don't know what's coming but
let's find out we're not done with the
judge says just yet
judge anderson the judge from round one
of the truth okay so just for update for
guys who haven't been following closely
judge anderson
[ __ ] slapped them he
he like destroyed them on the first
complaint
and everyone was like wow we when they
filed the second one against me we're
like wow we really hope it's the same
judge because he has no patience for
them
and it's well let's just watch h3
lawsuit has declined to take on
round two of the h3 triller
lawsuit saying that port ordered
plaintiff to show
why the separate alleged infringers
named in the action
were properly joined plaintiff had no
well-pleaded facts that the defendants
did anything other than
operate independently the judge is
saying that this case
is so separate from the others there's
no reason he should take it
on to his docket and denied the transfer
to his court
one more time to say that plaintiff had
no
well pleaded facts and that remains the
case
in this lawsuit i'm interested to see
what the judge assigned
does next i have no idea what that means
well she kept saying that their
lawsuit's so thin they don't have
well-pleaded facts which means like when
you file a lawsuit
you need facts like on this show at this
time
on this time stamp this is when they did
the damage you know what i mean
and they don't do any of that and she
was saying like
we need to get uh
she was saying that this could be easily
thrown out just for not having well
pleated facts
i don't know obviously she's not my
attorney so but
but i don't know what this means so i
guess it's not as exciting as i thought
i don't know who's judge anderson but it
sounds good he's the guy who [ __ ]
slapped him the first time
agent anderson i like him oh her
description here maybe this is helpful
he oh judge anderson legend astrix
legend legendary judge anderson
was asked by triller to take on round
two
of the trailer h3 lawsuit this would
make
litigation potentially easier to
coordinate for triller
i guess they're just taking short trying
to take a shortcut like the whole
lawsuit is a big shortcut
judge anderson is having none of it says
the cases are not related denied the
motion
but not without stating the complaint
lacked well-pleaded facts one last time
i guess in his opinion he keeps [ __ ]
slapping them it sounds like he's just
um not allowing this technical thing of
like grouping it together but it's not
like it's dismissed
no it sounds like they keep trying to
take shortcuts
to like save money they're like okay
we're going to remove everyone and just
do h3
they're like no you have to i don't i
actually don't understand this
i'd like to call her not like for legal
advice but just to have like a breakdown
because i don't i don't think that my
attorneys would want to necessarily
you want us to dm her on twitter or
something see if she wants to call in
yeah let me that would be [ __ ] epic
that'd be amazing here let me jammer
could we follow each other
oh or eden alexander said about to bust
my
matter of law shirt from the first i
know i know well you know
you know we're gonna have to be selling
matter of law part twos
you know i gotta merge the [ __ ] out of
this to help to raise money right
like lock him up with jake free ethan
shirts
something is about too much so i gotta
sell some like call
the lawsuit super bowl kind of memes
like super bowl
super bowl two hopefully not there's not
three
yo you available
you'll be able to call into our show
here oh so um people are saying it just
means that it's gonna go to another
judge
so so why would they why would they want
the same judge
because i think it was out of the
district they they're they were like
suing in the wrong district
the whole thing was a mess because
obviously we're in california and they
were trying to
whatever not interesting disappointed
disappointed
okay whatever and see if she responds
though because
she is interesting anyway so keemstar is
a snitch
so keemstar who as you all know is the
worst person in the world
stand up fella admits that he snitched
and i guess he takes great pride and
the thing the thing about keemstar's
you know what actually let me talk about
this first on the last episode we were
like
where's the [ __ ] why do you have a edica
folder on your desktop you remember
or like you're so psychotic so keemstar
thought he'd be cute
and make an ntf of keemstar's desk
or nft of keemstar's desktop except
there's one folder missing
the one that we all thought was the
super creepiest
he's like look he's like look i'm gonna
make a joke out of this
yeah self-aware
[Laughter]
except where's the edica folder that we
all saw yeah
and the top comment is keem we're going
to need an explanation on the edica
folder
like all of the comments without that of
course of course because of course he's
just drawing attention
it's like he's so stupid he's actually
did he sell any of these i'm curious can
i tell if he sold any bids
uh i don't know no active bids yet
killing it
game starts crushing it with these hot
memes literally zero bids
should we bid i think that would be
yeah what's the let's see um
oh here he's got a few sails
he has a bit of zero but wait he minted
it and then he put it on sale
10 editions for zero eve so he gave it
away
it's just so he wouldn't be embarrassed
that nobody bought it
i say so somebody bought it for .005
eth okay no he said he listed it for
zero
it's right but you can bid more than
zero
you know what i would pay for the
screenshot of that you know what
let's make an nft of the etiquette
folder
the correct one and that's the real
[ __ ]
uh obviously not but
such a [ __ ] weirdo yeah exactly
so keemstar thinks he's like playing 3d
chess
so keemstar in an effort to i guess
3d chess is just like normal right
not the best time to mess that up sound
like an idiot
so keemstar
whose main goal in life i guess is to
try to like ruin my life or something
as uh he's
going against his own self-interest in
all of youtube's
by snitching on me to trill
here's in his own words
um i don't think trailers looking to go
to war with like a creator you know what
i
mean
no they are they they are i talked to
him
so that's just so banks goes why would
trillar go to war with the creator
keemstar says no they are i talk to him
that's just part one here's
the part where um one of his friends
explicitly says the following
keemstar called into nick's stream and
he said look yeah i did snitch the
thriller all right i snitched them i
told him that he admitted to pirating
your fight on the show and and sure
enough something happened to ethan
so [ __ ] them because ethan's been trying
to go after me and go after
hell my right to own a kid that's what
keemstar said and that's true
like literally last week the last
episode we took a look at on the h3
podcast
they're literally talking about a
keemstar shouldn't have a kid
um i i wish keemstar didn't have a kid
but i didn't say he shouldn't have a kid
these kids are so demented bro so he
goes i'm gonna snitch on h3 to triller
and [ __ ] up all of fair use
for all of youtube just to get a one-up
on ethan
that's [ __ ] up
so this is my breadcrumb theory is like
obviously keemstar doesn't know when
that trailer he's a [ __ ] nobody
so he but he's friends with jake paul he
was you remember he was defending jake
paul being like
um he's like
i totally believe jake paul and this
person accusing jake paul
is lying because she could have just
turned her head
so he's friends with jake paul so i
think he just told jake paul who already
hates me
and jake paul told this one other guy
anyone that we criticize on the show can
start immediately like
the end it's so great dude it's wild
like bryce hall started tweeting at me
and i know that keemstar's
keemstar was involved because they
always end up tweeting out the same
video of me being like this you
yeah it's like always the same videos
like oh my god keep i can't believe
gabriel
is like hey you want some dirt you have
some dirt on h3
yeah yeah it's like bryce hall was
tweeting at me being like oh
old man why are you talking [ __ ] i was
like okay dude
lay off the steroids bro so cool so he
snitched um
great really really nice let me know
because i got a [ __ ] files on top of
files to swing back
at little did i know that his father
he had files on files on etica yeah he's
just such a nice
guy he came yeah
yeah he's a sweetheart a lovable
psychopath
um but it's fine you know we're dealing
with it
but um
well the point of course talking about
that is
since we noticed keemstar had that etiqa
folder on his desktop
and it you know really disturbed all of
us
we were actually able to leverage some
of our here's the screenshot for the
record
where he uh you know
oops did not include where is it top
top top left edica top left that's the
most accessible one
spotify etica steem etika
uh so we were we actually hacked into
keemstar's
computer i know i'm i'm confessing to a
crime here so
hopefully keemstar is just sticking on
me to the fbi well he's gonna just throw
it in the folder
yeah throw it in the hd crimes here's
another one for your folder [ __ ]
timestamp disconcert send it to the fbi
yes we hacked into your computer
and we found what a bunch of
thumbnails for upcoming
drama alert videos and you guys are not
going to believe
some of the videos we found he's working
on seems like he's really kind of
expanding the horizon of uh his content
too
really so here we go
guys my favorite beard dye
and makeup palette getting into makeup
tutorials yeah
yeah keemstar is working on a beauty
palette
is daytime uh kilometer routine
getting ready getting ready for work in
the morning
very important stuff uh the next one oh
no oh no so this is an episode he was
planning but cancelled
after the tragic death of his friend of
course after you know
epstein was in the news he says fun
times
with my best friend forever it's a
picture of keemstar with epstein
at his private island fun time what's
too bad that's shocking that would have
gone before
i understand why i didn't post that one
though that is a shocking admission for
him to make
wow
next one you know how to make custom
jorts
oh that's nice because keemstar is
always wearing shorts
as you know a man of class and taste
and so he's actually he is planning to
do a tutorial on
george those are jean shorts by the way
i've always wondered how he did that
pretend to be a good person yeah where
do you find those right
yeah all right oh no keemstar
oh no
now this is of course this classic video
where he's angrily calling a gentleman
by the name of alex
a racial slur starting with the letter n
what and he's replaying those here on
drum alert
kind of a little retrospective
you think it's a reenactment maybe he
was gonna reenact it kind of got the
glasses
back yeah oh crap
his beard they messed up his beard what
is this
it's a barber lawsuit oh my god
my barber messed me up dog it looks like
keemstar is gonna have a lawsuit on his
hand with his barber or maybe his
oh man who knew that's what he's hiding
under the beard that explains a lot
which is kind of true that's keemstar
without a beard folks
oh my goodness how i destroyed fair use
on youtube
snit and this is him on the phone
snitching to triller
interesting wow
this is the moment he snitched to
triller wow
we got it on camera which is kind of
true yeah he goes i'm going to destroy
fairies on youtube but as long as i can
just get
put ethan klein through a little bit of
a pain in the ass then it's all good
you know interesting he also was like
three feet tall which i didn't know
not to like short uh not to like short
shame
but like this ice cream comb he's only
like 10 times taller than this ice cream
cone
yeah really cross the line i'm sorry
you're right
oh flipping alcohol prices for big
profits
he's selling alcohol to kids it looks
like
kim juice game juice keem juice
that's inappropriate sounds like
something he'd do though doesn't it
[Music]
david duke interview oh wait a minute
that i can actually see happening
ironically
david duke of course famously uh
former head of the kkk or something i
don't know if he's the head he was a
grand a grand dragon or one
dragon wizard graham wizard yeah grand
dragon sounds like some
no that's that's a real kick they're
dragons really all
it's still doesn't sound like so white
supremacy it sounds like
no the whole it's all it's it's i know
wizards it's all like cosplay for
weirdo white supremacists are using that
grand they call themselves the grand
wizard
they really do yeah the wizard i didn't
know dragon though that sounds like
what yeah uh
the grand cowboy yeah
something white trash what's that then i
just looked it up grand
dragon yeah grand dragon dr samuel
greene in atlanta georgia
flanked by children yeah i mean it's a i
want to be a dragon
[Music]
um
oh here's another one top five lives
i've ruined
interesting that he keeps tally tony
that's of course the uh old streamer he
accused of being a p
word falsely alex as we all know
scarce oh i'm on the list ethan i don't
see i won't say you've ruined my life
the ice cream kit
[Music]
you guys are the ice cream kid pull that
up just for recollection
keemstar ice cream kid
prank he says this is fake you're
responsible for this if
you he says this is fake but if it is
this is the best i've ever
planned so we got you
modern warfare 3 for the xbox do you
have an xbox
no guess what we got you an xbox too
and a controller so you can play that
game isn't that awesome
cool giving back you ready to do this
hold over
bring it look at it look at it
why did you do this
oh i'm doing that but at the end
here we're fans of the bad kids show
happy thanksgiving jaden this is just a
joke it was just for a video okay
so i got you some ice cream cool
so epic don't you guys love keemstar
can you imagine he goes oh we were just
kidding he goes oh we were just kidding
yeah that kid was definitely happening
it is literally that kid is not having a
good time
yo we were just kidding look how much
joy by the way you could tell this guy
feels bad he's like i'm sorry but
keemstar is about back being like
yeah baby
[Laughter]
can someone explain how
you can live with yourself while being
keemstar
no conscience like so anyway he
this kid just a little retrospective
about this kid is actually the ice cream
kid makes the list so
he's still in therapy to this day
uh here's keemstar in the woods they
will never find the bodies
ela they will never find the bodies
very important stuff
cops are looking for me
[Laughter]
oh keemstar is suing
[Music]
a theme park he hates roller coasters
because apparently
he finds the top the height limitation
discriminatory
interesting oh here he is with his best
friend face blanks
our new business is not a scam they say
and they have a picture of a pyramid
with team at the top
and his followers at the bottom looks
like a pyramids game but they've assured
us it's not
a scam
oh and this is my favorite ela i was
born in the wrong generation
death to all jews what was that keemstar
death to all jews
[Music]
disgusting
well there you have it
[Music]
yep we've hacked into his desktop and
those are all
genuine videos he's planning i'm looking
forward to a lot of those
yeah i got notification i hit that bell
notifications on
born in the wrong generation
that one shocked especially with him
saying death to all jews that's just
out of that's just out of pocket
even for him even for a dude that has an
ethical folder on his desktop
that's too far right
[Laughter]
we have fun don't we folks
oh do we have speaking of keemstar
oh here this is [ __ ] hilarious just
unrelated but fake you know i've been
calling
faze banks phase blanks i think he's
[ __ ] because his perpetually
horribly like brain dead takes so faced
blanks commented on my
making fun of him on the recent podcast
here is this take you guys should enjoy
this
i think he's [ __ ] stupid to be honest
and it's funny because he refers to me
as
face blanks says i'm dumb um
h3 if you're listening to this i'm
infinitely smarter than you
and um infinitely more successful than
you and i don't know he's
infinitely smarter you guys it can't
even be measured
his intellect is beyond is beyond
measuring
face blanks he's blank i just love that
we have a sound bite of him yeah if i
if i'm so stupid then how come we got a
sound bite of you saying phase blanks
i'm infinitely smarter than you and um
infinitely more successful than you
you know what's ironic ela the only way
his iq could be infinitely different
than mine
is if it was zero checkmate phase blinks
zero iq turns out i'm infinitely smarter
it says also oh and he goes i'm
infinitely more successful i was like
bro i didn't even say anything i never
said you were unsuccessful
insecure much yeah yeah listen to this i
think he's [ __ ] stupid
me too trust me i'm reminded every day
how dumb i am
h3 if you're listening to this i'm
infinitely smarter than you
and um infinitely more successful than
you and i don't have to make [ __ ]
infinitely more successful i can't
measure how successful he is to
dumb youtube videos with you know
cosplaying with trisha paytas and
punching down and making up [ __ ] about
every other creator and
i'm not gonna lie down i thought he was
more successful than you yeah
if he's more successful yeah wait a
minute
you can't be both blank blanks
i'm infinitely smarter than you and
infinitely more successful
and i don't like you punching down on me
this is [ __ ] stupid this is the
dumbest man
one of the dumbest men in existence
right here folks
face blanks that's why we call them face
blanks
which is hilarious and now we have a
sound bite of him saying face blank so
checkmate dumbass blanks
yeah i'm dumb too
i'm a dumb idiot but i never said you
were not successful by the way so that's
just your own weird projection
yeah like that was never part of that
he's like listen
i have scammed so many kids of cs go
lottos
i have so much more money than you hey i
didn't i never argued that
but hey don't punch down i'm infinitely
smarter than you and
i'm infinitely more successful than you
by the way that's a joke that's a
alligator that's just a
ru i've i heard uh allegations that he
was involved in cs golotto i don't know
for sure
that is just a statement without so you
know legal disclaimers and all that
not a lot of love has a correction for
me got to correct me love
um right he owned cisco wild allegedly
oh the face oh so i wasn't wrong because
he seems like the type of dude to scam
kids on cs go
gambling that's why i made the pyramid
scheme thing
he's like bro i'm infinitely more
successful than you
face blanks
[Laughter]
i love him this guy's such a
these guys are such goons i mean look at
them they're like the frat boys that
never grew up look at these two
unloved these guys were not loved
growing up
i'm sorry that seems low but i mean how
do you end up like this
you know what that's not their fault
though i love them
i want to love them face blanks
it's not his fault his head is empty
i feel like i could be friends with faze
blanks
do you think he was gonna have to stop
calling him face blanks probably if you
want that to happen
well he's the one that said it not me i
don't know if you would hang out with
someone who's infinitely
dumber than him that's just me like
like he's like hey ethan you wanna hang
you wanna play video games i'm like
i think he's [ __ ] stupid yeah
i agree we do agree on that trust me
oh this 30 second clip is like such a
jewel to me
when i heard this i was just giggling
dude really thought i was i think he's
[ __ ] stupid to be honest and it's
funny because he refers to me as
face blanks says i'm dumb um
h3 if you're listening to this i'm
infinitely smarter than you
and um infinitely more successful than
you and i don't know infinitely
anyone who says that about themselves it
can't be true
it's so insecure bro it's like the most
he's losing insecurity
i'm hella smart and successful bro
oh and ethan if you're listening i'm
hella smart and hella successful
some nights are just so they're so clean
they're so crisp
yes christmas come early from faze
blanks
chase blanks
it's so awesome
yeah that was that was my favorite that
was my favorite thing
why can't we oh i don't want to see any
too good but why can't we be friends
i feel like i could be friends with faze
blanks i think keemstar is too evil
to go to college first yeah i have to go
to like uh
physical therapy i have to learn how to
use like the
i have to learn how to speak again you
gotta get the diamond ring in the call
of duty
i need to go to re physical uh i
it's like my br you know when you get
like a terrible head trauma and you have
to re-educate yourself
how to talk that's me compared to his
infinite intellect
face blanks is crushing algorithms that
we can crushing algorithms in his sleep
bro
faze blanks is mining bitcoin in his
sleep
with his brain
[Laughter]
face blank he's crushing algorithms like
his brain's processing power uses the
equivalent energy of the country of
ireland yeah
yeah exactly did phase just watching my
algorithms get across
exactly phase blanks is making don jr
blush with how he's crushing algorithms
face blanks blanks i can't believe he
said it
i think that's the best nickname i've
ever came up with anyone for um for
anyone
i'm just so proud of it and the fact
that he said it i just can't get over it
anyway enough about those bozos
you want to see if you got a dm back oh
sure let me check my phone real fast
i got a text from my lawyer facebook
what is love's update on thinking about
his family being
shot in the face every day all right
that was last week yeah oh
i forgot have you been have you been
doing that love
oh yeah bite okay so just the update
thank you oh my god the chat reminded me
i almost forgot
i was like elo what are you talking
about okay so last time we watched a
video garyvee
saying he goes i want you to sit at home
for five minutes and
genuinely imagine someone you love being
shot in the face
um once a day genuinely sit there for
five minutes and make pretend one of
them got shot in the face
that was his tip to finding happiness in
life
so love tell me about your happiness
your schedule first of all
tell me about once a day i went all out
tell me about your first of all like
your your uh
tell me about your ritual what i was
thinking
like the only time i don't do anything
normally is in my bed
so i just took it down so every time
before i
before i fell asleep i think all right
and then who did you imagine was being
shot in the face
uh well i went through the list i went
through my whole family
i had seven days on me so pretty much my
whole family
okay right and what did you feel
did you feel it really or did it feel
silly or did you really feel sadness
doing it
it sucked it it's really terrible i
don't recommend it
say like a quick tutorial to get
depression i feel like
you choose depression speed run okay so
wait this is really interesting
yeah so you would lay in bed you would
imagine for five minutes straight would
you time it or would you say that's
enough
no yeah pretty much until i'm completely
just
if after three minutes you're just it's
enough kind of bored of it
yeah so you didn't follow his rules
though he said five minutes
yeah then maybe that's why it didn't
work that's right yeah i think you might
need to do it again this week and report
back
no no way well love you said everyone
that
everyone you loved the most did you
event did you imagine me being shot in
the face
well didn't he say family like family
okay i was just testing his loyalty
otherwise of course i would have thought
about you thank you
just testing you so immediate
so immediately after following gary's v
advice you would come out of this trance
and
what what would you be feeling
just pure sadness horrible
horrible and then you would go
[Music]
and then you would go to bed when you
woke up the next day did you have any
like appreciate appreciation like that
didn't happen
this person is alive and everything's
okay
no just
it was just a bad time before i went to
sleep that's all
damn that sounds like it was a bust i
was thinking about it one day because we
were kind of laughing about it
and i was thinking to myself like if i
really tried to go there in my mind
i did i couldn't even let myself go
there because it just seems awful
she seems like what's the point it's
just bad it's almost like
enabling like uh this intrusive thoughts
right but like times 1000
and it's like why would you want to do
that it's because it's like all it's
like all these motivational speakers
they
they say something that sounds really
profound but it's
like shocking it's really yeah so yeah i
cannot try to imagine
for who that this would be good for i
mean i'm
doing pretty good like i'm not i'm i'm
just chilling
like i'm not sad generally i'm pretty
happy
so this would just make me sad but maybe
for someone who's sad already
thinking that something could be worse
well gary that might be the thing
right gary vee seems like a guy who's
got it all together right
he says the biggest thing for my
happiness play the sound bite
[Music]
the biggest thing for my happiness like
he said he says
nothing makes him happier nothing maybe
once a day
genuinely sit there for five minutes and
make pretend one of them got shot in the
face
and then he says nothing contributes
more to my happiness
that's so messed up than doing it no way
he's a psychopath yeah that's pretty
crazy all right well
you know what love came around on that
because he was
a little bit more skeptical last week
but after doing it for a week it's like
gary's uh love has your opinion of
garyvee changed after performing this
exercise
well yeah of course i'm near
to near full depression like
i don't like him anymore oh what if like
this is step one and then step two
branding his name on your genitals
step two is imagine you are the one
shooting them
oh stop it that is so good you could you
have a future in self-help gurus yeah
you could sell that course you need to
start a seminar
wow are you willing to do that next week
no i'm just kidding don't do that please
well i mean first thing for the show no
i don't want you to
i don't want you to suffer love first of
all
join my i i'm sorry
i'm sorry you went through that yeah
thank you for doing it
i mean it was a real i'm actually i
actually found thought the experiment
was really interesting so
i appreciate your putting yourself
through that
yeah it works you're okay though you're
all good
yeah i'm fine as i said i'm just happy
i'm feeling
so that was just like a momentarily
sadness
that's all it was i i knew you know i
and i knew that sounded like a terrible
idea
but i'm glad we got some empirical
evidence to back it up
yeah i mean and and love being like a
well-adjusted
happy kind of person i feel like if you
were actually depressed that might tip
you over the edge i mean
yeah i don't know possibly yeah that's
just kind of irresponsible to be honest
you shouldn't really be putting that
[ __ ] out there
genuinely i love those are genuinely
like no missing this is not hyperbole
i am literally instructing you all
thank you um one more thing the chat is
asking if ab did it too
oh did you do it a.b i didn't but after
visiting home
yeah i might try ela's theory to help me
fall asleep really
having some beef with the family back
home yeah
i came home and like half my cousins are
now who are you kidding
crazy right ring like what conspiracy
theorists
yeah like
not to that degree but i see some of
them possibly dip in their toes and
yeah different types of that
yeah we got in a fight before we got
home i got picked up from the airport
and
we got a fight before i got back to the
house
what what were you guys arguing about
i'm honestly embarrassed to say that i'm
even i mean i don't want to get anywhere
yeah
yeah that sucks really it's that
it's i'm so curious wait dan you know
the details because dan said
no no no but i'm just i'm i'm getting
the vibe he doesn't
necessarily want to share that bubble
you brought it up yeah
i'm gonna come no just i don't know
just i'd love to know i mean people
getting their information from memes
facebook uh news sources right
okay well they should he you should
listen to the podcast this is the only
source of uh
correct and accurate news well you're
back soon ab
we miss you thank you miss you guys
yeah forget a b lena's like [ __ ]
thank you lean is impossible to live
without
uh i'm just kidding we love you i miss
and i i look forward to seeing you guys
both
um okay so moving on
we got a lot to talk about here still we
got the craft mail i'm sorry
the lawyer wants to know when can we
talk while you do that
i saw people asking for a nail how long
we've been going down
update uh about two hours holy [ __ ]
it's gonna be a long episode y'all let's
party can you zoom in
uh will that work yeah uh give me one
second
wow it's little teddy bears
oh is it really yeah so cute nice
it looks awesome i'm sorry guys i'm just
uh this is urgent about this did it take
a
did it take a long time to do it yeah no
it's
i'm just setting up a time to talk to
him okay yeah
um sorry what's that oh emily wants to
call in
right yeah i was wondering she wants to
call in okay so
so i'll send you the zoom link should i
send her your email what should i do
i'll just give you the zoom link right
now and she can uh she can dial in
okay this is exciting dude we have so
much to do
we still have like some great stories
here there's gonna be like a 10 hour ep
let's go baby
it's thursday maybe yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah it's thursday i deserve to
talk to a lawyer i deserve to be sued
yeah
yo are you say where'd you send it dan
in uh
i got it i got dude we can get emily the
legend to call in
emily all right send her the link okay
i will keep an eye out on zoom for when
she signs in
she's coming hey hey i feel like i'm
about to talk to carlos this is a
celebrity [ __ ]
hey hey hey
all right let's talk lawsuit look at
nitty gritty on this [ __ ]
exciting so she has the link dance so
keep an eye for that um
in the meantime craft
mail oh has really
yup put out a
contest that was made for zach
we are about to win zach ten thousand
dollars
and make him the face the new face of
craft mayonnaise wait
she's already she's signed in do you
want okay to do this first or do you
want me to
oh [ __ ] i guess so this can wait yeah
yeah yeah let's take her
yeah a little tease for later in the
episode you got all right
uh give me one second you guys are not
going to want to miss that craft mayo
segment
because i'll tell you what
zack is winning that 10 grand so give me
one second
emily d
i see her oh so do i let me uh pin
the video can you hear me emily
d baker esquire attorney at law
celebrity attorney
youtube extraordinaire welcome to the
show and thank you for calling in on
such short notice
not a worry i was picking my kid up from
school and my twitter exploded
and then i saw your dm and i was like
hey where i mean i've been talking about
this suit i feel like
for weeks but it's been the shortest
lawsuit
since that fight so you know yeah i know
it's good to see you both do you what do
you think first of all
the fact that the short is the fight is
short
does i'm wondering like is it my fault
that they had a shitty fight like
if i'm covering fair use right and they
say oh you should you showed the whole
fight
two minutes it's like i'm sorry it's not
my fault your fight sucked
so under fair use they look at the
length of the clip you use but they also
look at does it diminish the value of
the thing and it was what five days
after the fight that you talked about it
yeah right
so how are they going to prove that they
had a diminished value
it was done and over it's not as if you
uploaded it
contemporaneously and people could
choose to go watch it there and not
watch the pay-per-view because it was so
many days later for comment
are you a lawyer or something i love the
way you explain that
i'm a lawyer or something i've been a
lawyer for over 15 years and i was a
district attorney so i don't
like uh using the courts for nonsense
there's a lot of
actual stuff that has to go through
court process they didn't plead a date
they didn't plead a time they it's
one of the worst pleadings i've ever
seen wow
so you know i'm glad first of all
i've been following your coverage i
think even back in the day during the
matt
haas lawsuit i i just i love hearing all
the different perspectives and stuff
because it's always nice to hear the
outside
opinion so what like in my case like i'm
a defendant on what
is a poorly conceived complaint that
is um
bordering on frivolous so so like
how do you as a private citizen or or
let's say a corporate entity or whatever
def certainly the underdog compared to
triller
um like like what's the remedy to that
how do you keep from getting [ __ ]
around
by these big media companies
so not legal advice but lawyer thoughts
um for anyone who's facing a lawsuit one
of the first things you want to do is
make sure you
actually get served i'm sure you haven't
been served yet
um and it's going to take them some
effort to do so they haven't even pled
that they know where your company is
because they're not suing you they're
suing the h3 podcast and they haven't
seemed to figure out what kind of legal
entity it is yet
so one of the things is if you see
something breaking in the news
and you haven't been served yet you have
to wait until they do process
and actually serve you because if they
don't serve you
then their lawsuit can be closed for
failure to go after it or failure to
prosecute so
you aren't really even in it until
you've been served with it even though
you're aware of it
at this point how
um it really depends on the court but
they have reasonably about a month
that they could get away with it they're
not going to find me what if i go
what if i go hide in a hole or somewhere
they could try to perfect service
later um but it would be it would be a
challenge because after that the court
will be like what is happening with the
suit why isn't it moving along
and after that then you get the 21 days
to respond to it but they have to serve
you first
and the court hasn't responded to this
suit yet
we saw that in the first suit when they
filed the amended complaint to bring you
in
the court had already said where are the
facts here please
so the court might take action on its
own or sue aspante as they call it
and say something about the suit because
it doesn't even plead a date so
the court might do things before you
even have to answer it
which would be interesting but that's a
conversation for you
and your lawyers to have whether you
want to reach out to the law firm or
whether you want to wait and be like hey
come find me
right that's interesting because this
lot you know what's funny about this
lawsuit is we didn't even find out about
it
until this big press release where
they're like we're suing h3 because they
you know play but that was like a week
after it's been filed
so as far as the clocks ticking it's
been two or three weeks already
and these guys don't are still they
don't they don't even
haven't even done the basic research to
identify
our business entity like you said they
they can ex try to extend service it
looked like
i pulled court documents today because i
got asked about the judge's denial of
the
of transferring it to a different court
what was that
so judge anderson who had the first case
who was
very sassy and threw it out and took pot
shots at the fact that the fight was
only two minutes long
um who dismissed all of the other
defendants
they moved to have him take the new suit
that they filed against the podcast
into his court and said hey we want you
to have the suit against the only
dependent left film daily
and bring the h31 here it makes it
easier for them the judge was like uh
these aren't related no
i don't want to look at your lawsuit i
don't want to look at you you can't come
to my court so it's staying with the
judge that it got assigned to
why would they want that one judge who's
asked them to have it i guess
because i was thinking i want that judge
you know what i mean
yeah i i was hoping that that judge
anderson would take it too so we could
smack it around a little bit more
because it was a very funny minute order
and he
i don't know if he's had interactions
with this law firm before
or if his research attorney has because
they took action on this lawsuit very
quickly
and it it made me wonder if they have
had similar suits
with this law firm before because once
you're
suss about something you're like oh
there you are again let's see
the old cell goodman thing
absolutely so i was hoping he would take
it
he didn't he said they're not similar
because they're separate actions and
they're totally separate things
but for triller it can make it easier
for them to coordinate discovery
and for coordinating motions and stuff
to have one judge hear them
got it it can make it more expensive for
them to be good
let's bleed them dry let's bleed their
billion dollar well
their billion dollar well um i want to
clarify something because
for the public there seems to be some
dispute about the nature of this law
this is a fair use lawsuit right i mean
ultimately
essentially yeah it's a copyright
lawsuit so fair use
is one of the defenses to copyright
infringement people can come in and say
you've infringed my copyright and you
can say
i've used your copyrighted works but
it's permissible because of fair use so
fair use is a defense
to an alleged copyright infringement
because at the heart of it
you can't use anyone's copyrighted
material
anywhere but then fair use allows you to
use it
for commentary which is really the
purpose that you use it for based on
what i watched and
and and so right if i if they're sending
me
an unreasonable what i perceive as a
very aggressive
unreasonable settlement offer or let's
say we go to court
and lose to them what kind of precedent
is this setting
for youtube community at large and how
youtubers rely so much on fair use with
how they you they oh i mean you know on
youtube it's very common
it's con it's norm the norm to be
interactive with other people's media
so how do you see this affecting youtube
if trailer is able to win
a lawsuit against us on this
it is hard for me to conceive of how
this lawsuit can even proceed because
they haven't played it well enough to go
forward
but if if they might they can still
amend the complaint if they modified it
and brought in facts
or in another scenario where somebody a
large company's going after
a youtube channel for fair use and
saying it's not fair use
each judge and each district decides
fair use based on these balancing
factors
and so it can set precedent but
it depends because each thing is so
factually specific
so it could be oh well in this case
because the clip was
or in a case because the clip was large
and the the overall thing wasn't
then um you know maybe it's not fair use
but that doesn't impact other cases that
aren't under that same fact scenario
i don't like and i'm normally not
as as open about how i feel about a suit
i normally just break them down and
explain what they mean
what i don't like is using the courts
for [ __ ] and
not pleading a date not linking a video
where you said something not making it
clear what the issue is
makes me feel like they're just trying
to gain traction for this website where
they're trying to get people to say hey
i watched the fight too this isn't a
parroting lawsuit they're trying to say
that it was redistributed but it wasn't
it was commentary
yeah and they didn't that's what they
could copyright strike the video
on youtube did what did they do did they
copy strike the no that's the other
thing they never
dmca they never claimed it they never
made any attempt to remedy the situation
uh you know and the other thing is like
let's just say they've made a settlement
offer i don't know if i'm allowed to
talk about that but i won't
but let's just say no yeah
okay even when the lawyer is shaking her
head no
because look what happens in so if
people were in settlement talks and i've
talked about this with other lawsuits
relating to other youtubers
once you go into settlement talks
everything that happens in there kind of
goes behind
a wall and then if that doesn't happen
in a lawsuit proceeds
nothing that happens in the course of
settlement talks can come into the
lawsuit
so it gives you some room to be candid
with things and really
put down like this is where we see this
case and this is where we're at
where are you at because that can't be
used against you going forward in the
lawsuit
because it's for the purposes of
settlement
now this court has a standing order
that prefers to go to mediation
so even if the case moves forward it
might end up in
court mediation anyway but they would
have to fix that complaint and i
imagine that the conversation between
lawyers would be like
would you like to provide a date or some
facts about what you're saying that
we've done
because at this point you're just saying
words that don't have meaning because
they're not
actually well pleated facts which is the
standard for a federal complaint
right but you know you're you say that
it's all about just trying to get people
to get
paid 49.99 i think that's my speculation
i think that's a very
good speculation
it feels i mean it's a very very good
speculation
there are other channels that have
uploaded the entire main card event that
will be in that first lawsuit
yeah mike i love your coverage of mike
fine mike
they have no idea there's a guy there's
i love that that was crazy there's a guy
his channel name is just mike he
uploaded the fight to youtube
and they put him in the lawsuit as just
mike
like they're just mike yeah no
other details no information just mike
yo
mike and of course their original
complaint
alleged that i was in a conspiracy with
mike to defraud right and everyone else
yeah and everyone it was a massive
conspiracy between all of us
so stupid but it also said that it
wasn't just a conspiracy that you were
all
agents of one another employees of one
another
they were alleging all of this
relational stuff that is and
mike's my buddy he's my best friend
shout out to mike wherever you are that
was sarcasm
right you're gonna add that to the
lawsuit oh yeah
well mike's off the lawsuit now [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah exactly sarcasm alert they kept
saying that
um nothing less than cyber criminals i
was waiting for the teddy fresh like
cyber criminal line of merch
oh that's a good one because i'm trying
i'm trying to think of good merch ideas
to help
just you know raise capital to ease the
blow
cyber criminal is great i was thinking
free ethan
lock up lock up jake paul like lock her
up you like that one
[Laughter]
no comment no comment but i like cyber
criminal that's really cool
it's what does your dude mike mike
just mike that's that's kind of your
meme but i hope you don't mind us taking
it just
mike you know i'm spartacus i'm mike
we're all
mike everyone's mike when the mischief
um nike satan cheese lawsuit went down
mischief made a shirt that they called
legal fees
and put the front of the lawsuit on the
shirt that they were selling
and it was hilarious that's pretty good
yeah that's a really i'm gonna i'm gonna
get creative with it for sure
um hey yeah
it's a pain in the ass it sucks lawsuits
lawsuits are stressful even when they're
totally [ __ ]
they can they be expensive assuming
i mean time on the phone with lawyers is
i mean unless it's me it's never fun
um and and i don't do transactional law
anymore i did years and years in court
but
taking these things through to prove
that they're [ __ ] can be expensive
and extensive and that's
part of the problem and i think that's
what judge anderson was trying to cut
off
was we're not doing this this is
ridiculous but lawyers can get in
trouble for
filing complaints that have no merit and
no basis
so at some point they're going to have
to prove that there's merit to this
and re saying that you re-upload and
distributed the fight and charge people
money on paypal isn't
yeah they said that they literally said
that in the new complaint that they
filed against us there's a
there's mention of paper yeah there's a
the one of the charges
is uh how do you call it it was called
transaction or conversion
conversion they say that we were
accepting money on paypal
okay what the [ __ ] it was from the other
one
yeah they just copy paste it from the
other one and forgot to erase it that's
how much effort they're putting into
this
it's i don't i don't know why you would
sign your name to this as an attorney
i don't i don't i can't conceive of the
point because the point is
not because they think you did something
wrong because otherwise they would
share right you said this you did this
here's the time stamp here's the clip
here's the video here's the date
they did none of that so to me it feels
like a publicity stunt
oh that's not a proper use of the courts
thank you for saying that
emily i appreciate that and you know
it's like what do you make of the
so they've got this whole big uh uh
lawsuit against all these people right
and the judge says i'm throwing this out
it's improper jointer
and then who who else have they filed
against from that original lawsuit
well none yet i keep looking on pacer
because i'm very curious
i imagine a lot of those websites
she said no other person but me right
just the h3 podcast and in the first one
they sued the h3 podcast and
h3 productions and they didn't resu h3
productions they just sued
the h3 podcast but they don't know if
that's
and do not help them with that they do
not know if that's
an llc a corporation um
they don't know they don't know what
legal entity that is yet
because they didn't do anything well
according to phase blinks i have an
infinitely low iq so i don't know
anything about anything
um
yeah what do you
i i have a question actually emily it
i have no idea if this actually would um
come into play but i i do know because
there was a very public one a few years
ago the whole thing with
uh devin nunes suing people for making
fun of him on twitter or whatever
there's like these laws that are
specifically to
get rid of frivolous lawsuits right it's
called like slap
law and stuff like that is that
something that potentially could come
into play here or is that not
really applicable in this situation so
the
the slap and anti-slap laws are
strategic litigation against public
participation
they're like laws that are to try to
stop people from using the courts
to get you to stop talking and to exert
your rights to
free speech and to stop you from
participating publicly
this being a copyright infringement suit
doesn't really play with the slap laws
because they're not trying to stop you
from doing something in the future
they're trying to fix something that
they're saying happened in the past
which if they had pled a date we would
know they're not trying to stop you from
talking going forward
got it okay that makes sense i'm just
curious but it's
it is they are very powerful laws and
the california slap
statutes are very powerful it's one of
the most common things i dealt with when
i worked for judges in the superior
court in la
was slap lawsuits they came up all the
time because people don't want other
people talking about them
what's your right what's your take on
triller is
a huge media company valued in you know
the billions of dollars i think
what is your take on why they
are putting apparently so little money
and effort
into this lawsuit it's just because it's
just a headline
but they gotta follow it through because
this is triller fight club
two llc they're not suing under triller
because trailers
involved in a pretty big lawsuit going
on with tick-tock
that's across multiple states going back
and forth and it's completely different
law firms
than what's going on in this suit so
who's making the decision
who's making the decisions for trailer
fight club 2 llc i believe it's
jake paul
i hope jake paul is not their legal
strategist
okay that's interesting to know so
they've got the whole
and then why it's funny they got yeah
got your hat that's their legal defense
you know they've they said it's the the
triller fight club 2 what triller fight
club 2
llc so what's the actual plaintiff is
there a
triller fight club one or is that the
event name or what
we don't not that i've seen so they made
it llc
does that make sense to make a llc for
one event
it's odd they could make it for one
event
to protect from losses so companies can
do that you see like
real estate investment companies doing
this where they section off each
property
so if they saw it as a property but this
might just be the wing that they run
all of the fights through and that this
is what they run the fight club through
or that they run each fight through a
separate llc which would be interesting
if they do
but they could do that and an llc is a
limited
uh liability is a partnership right so
does that mean it's owned by two people
well llcs are limited liability
companies they an llp would be a limited
liability partnership but they could be
owned
by one person by many people they can be
owned by another company
is it public who owns this llc uh this
llc
the llp uh the llc we could probably
find it i just haven't looked it up
okay but it's a delaware limited
liability company yeah because i'd love
to know
love to know who these people are it
could be that triller
owns triller fight club 2 llc
and then so it's so funny okay so who
owned trailer fight club 1
llc who owns trailer fight club too is
it trailer is a trailer
fight club two owns trailer fight club
one llc
we're gonna have to do a deep dive into
who owns the companies it's interesting
tracing them back and delaware
doesn't put as much information up as
other states because this is a delaware
limited liability company
operating in california emily can you
tell me why do all these companies go
set up businesses in delaware
i sure can they think that there's tax
benefits to them to doing that and some
additional protections to doing it
um i actually like wyoming a little bit
better but when you're operating out of
out of california like they say that
they are all the laws in california
apply anyway
so then it becomes whether they're using
it as a holding company
and whether they're using it as a way to
move money between companies which
is not improper um and a lot of
companies do that when i did a deep dive
into jacqueline hill's corporations
she has a number in delaware and then a
few in florida so it's not uncommon
people perceive that delaware adds more
protection but if you're operating in
california
california's laws all apply yeah we're
operating in like
any state it could be any one of them
nobody could possibly know that
just saying absolutely yeah who knows
or i don't even know i might even just
be an individual on
on you know i'm saying might not even be
a company at all
always possible you know what i'm gonna
come out now and tell you my
company name it's trailer fight club
part three
llc fight club three llc
coming up now
you know what i'm gonna we gotta have
you keep calling in
i love the legal perspective if you're
available and happy to
i'm happy to i legal commentary is my
favorite especially in the youtube space
you know between the james charles
employment lawsuit and this it's
we're i think we're going to see more
lawsuits in the employment law area with
regard to influencers but
this stuff the the improper use of
copyright really frustrates me because
when copyright is actually infringed on
it should be pursued
right when it's stupid it makes it worse
for everybody
and it's so obvious if i'm like like
mike
god bless his soul he infringed on
copyright with peace and love mike
with peace and love you know shout out
to mike wherever you are
[Laughter]
fight club llc uh roman numeral 1-5
the thing is they didn't seem to
copyright strike that either the whole
fight still uploaded
so they're not interested in getting the
fight taken down
because if they were there's options to
do that right that's not what they did
yeah they're just trying to maximize
damages or
they just don't give a [ __ ] and they
it's it's all odd but you know um
um what's your take by the way since you
mentioned james charles we're about to
talk about it what's your take on
okay okay am i allowed to have dan shave
my ass as
james charles for example alleged or his
his ex-employee
alleges that he had her shave
his ass i mean i'd be happy to so it
would kind of be moot but
but dan's just putting it out there
right but she might have not been
willing so
okay well let's see let's just say ice
go dan i need you to shave my ass for a
bit
illegal or legal sister snatched
so it really depends on the employment
relationship and if your employee feels
harassed and if that's part of their job
thing if it's like
hey it's for a bit there's no harm but
we've seen hey it's for a bit go
really really wrong with david dobrik so
in a traditional workplace environment
your bare butt
at any of your employees is going to be
a problem and california's employment
laws
do not favor the employer so
you know the problem with harassment in
the workplace
is you could ask dan to shave your butt
dan could be totally cool with it
but another employee in the room could
feel harassed and that employee could
sue you
so it's not even just it's between you
and dan
i didn't mean it okay am i allowed to
slam
dan into the side of an excavator and uh
potentially kill him
i'm gonna go with a hard stop on
potentially killing people
um i also think that the
you know the whole vlog squad should
have probably been employees
it's interesting to me that there aren't
any employee lawsuits because i got the
sense
from a lot of what i've watched that
they were not paying vlog squad members
to be on the block
pretty interesting right horrifying and
shocking
and well yeah the currency is for the
cloud
yeah that's that and that's not even a
joke that's not like usually we say like
cloud as a joke
they were that was actually the currency
you can't pay people an exposure in
california it's
not the law yeah that's super
interesting i bet none of them you know
what's funny
i'm sorry you look good i mean that's
jake paul's currency too
clout clout i'll pay you in clout
ironically jake didn't pay them he took
money from them
that was what the team 10 house was is
that yep
he actually he was reverse employing
them
uh yeah but what you say about
employment is so interesting regarding
the vlog squad because i guarantee none
of them
have even thought about that like oh i'm
entitled to something or
i need to be employed you know that's
that's very interesting
yep california changed their employment
laws um
a while back there was a supreme court
case and i will not bore you with all of
it but
the way independent contractors are
classified changed and i talked about
this with creators a few years ago
because if you're you know somebody like
shane dawson and you have android swifty
following you around with the camera
he's employed by you he's not a
contractor
you make videos he's filming you that's
an important role
that makes sense it sounds like our
hunch was correct that going out with
the excavator
unlicensed and unsupervised and slamming
one of your homies into it is got to be
a legitimacy
i wonder what the agreement has been
behind the scenes because
if cases like that and i've been part of
cases that have settled before they've
even gone to court you normally get
i call them you suck letters some people
call them shakedown letters
but you normally get a letter saying if
you don't do this
i am going to sue you for this we should
probably have a chat and you do
pre-litigation negotiations and in that
you can have people sign all kinds of
agreements never talk about it
never sue you again or turn over all the
footage pay all the medical bills pay
this amount
they could have resolved this behind the
scenes for
you know you're gonna allow me to to use
your footage you're going to allow me
to do it here i'm not going to sue you
whether there could be criminal
liability there for negligence in
utah is interesting to me i don't know
if utah will pursue it but
they they're even if they resolve it
civilly it doesn't
um remove the potential that that was a
a assault or something that's a that's
another interesting wrinkle right
is that the state independent of
whatever jeff and david agree on
can pursue legal action against david
yes they can and that's the interesting
thing with me about this triller
settlement website it's like okay well
you can go and say oh yeah i pirated the
fight here's my 50 bucks and my name and
my information
but that doesn't stop you from the
potential
criminal pirating that people can go
after too it's not just a civil case
there can be it's unlikely but there can
be criminal liability there
so you can't really have someone admit
to it and say oh we won't go after you
because
you're not the only party involved in
that the fcc can go after you too
so do you recommend people going to that
website and paying 49.99
as a lawyer as a lawyer i don't give
legal advice on the internet
right right as a private as a private
citizen
yeah as a private as a human i would
never go to a website and say
yeah i did this thing here's where to
find me no i would never
hi my name is
they're suing you and they still don't
know where you are what your corporation
is or the date of the thing that
happened right i don't have a whole lot
of faith
that they're going to try to track down
vpns and find everyone who might have
watched this
right subpoena they're gonna subpoena
vpns
i track down uh individuals who click
the link
i mean and also what's the damages for
clicking a link i mean it's a 50
fight right uh i think that would be the
maximum would be the amount of the fight
i don't know how you could get more than
that
so sounds pretty scary that sounds
pretty scary
i don't like using the court system for
nonsense so
and we love that about you thank emily
well i've
really enjoyed this chat i found it
really insightful would you
i i would like you to be now today
our legal correspondent emily baker
i am honored and i am happy i am happy
to help
break down the legal [ __ ] that's
happening around the interwebs happy to
do it
and uh hidden within this conversation
was an engagement
letter that you uh unknowingly
verbally agreed to and your rate is zero
dollars an hour
thank you oh clout i get clout thank you
yeah
is that acceptable form of currency
i'm happy to come on you know how to
contact me yeah so if you need anything
please reach out and ask i'm sorry
thank you and by the way emily d baker
is your youtube channel right yeah i put
a link to
your channel and on the twitter what's
your twitter
i'm the emily debaker everywhere on the
internet
there you have it yep emily thanks for
calling that was awesome
appreciate it thanks for having me on um
it's a pleasure and i'm sure i will talk
to you guys soon
thank you so much take care thanks for
calling
cool fantastic that was
i'm still staring at emily so okay there
she goes
it always takes time i'm only nice
things but i go
wow that was such a great call and i'm
staring at her trying to turn off them
that was such a great call she's awesome
yep
there you have it folks oh there's one
other question i wanted to ask her if i
was going to go to jail
oh dang it can we get her back on i
think we know the answer to that yeah
because keemstar keeps saying i'm going
to jail
oh faze blanks by the way who's
infinitely smarter than me predicted i
was going to go to jail for six months
really or maybe not maybe not no no no
no no i thought
he said he was the one that said that no
i don't think yeah his vast intellect
never mind
face blanks to be fair to blanks
between those two he's definitely the
brains of the ark he is infinitely
smarter
than thank you star yes yes i will i
will
gladly say that he's crushing algorithms
compared to what keemstar
wow shout out to emily d baker
legendary what a great call
thank you emily that was fun
really interesting insight on everything
especially the david dobrik [ __ ] like
whoa
imagine it's always funny to talk to a
lawyer that's following like youtube
stuff
i love it because most lawyers
will have no idea they have no idea
that's why it's so hard to find a good
lawyer when it comes to like
you could tell the lawyers who did the
triller lawsuit don't know [ __ ]
anything
about youtube space right so it's so
important to find someone who actually
understands all the wrinkles and stuff
[Music]
damn anyway
you guys want to talk about mayonnaise
so we have a call
we have a call at um and we have got
time
but we have a call with our lawyer well
we've been going for almost
three hours that's great we're having
too much fun out here today boys
maybe uh let's do the mayo is the well
we gotta do the mayo the finale
i guess there's not much more to say
about james charles lawsuit yeah i was
gonna say
we were gonna do a whole i did yeah i
kind of went over it just now well i'll
just give you the gist of it
and then we can end on a bang uh he's
being sued
by an ex-employee oh no
during this time she would produce she
worked a bunch she claimed she worked 80
hours a week yadda yadda
uh she's suing for wrongful termination
unpaid overtime disability
discrimination
and forcing to shave his ass no that's
not what
that charge is failure to provide
reasonable accommodations
yeah i read the article um uh in insider
um and if you want me to just give you
like the kind of the key allegations of
what
she's saying well she also claims he
regularly used the n
word with the hard r they put in
parentheses
and then this is this i like this is a
funny detail
insider reached out to people who knew
james in high school to corroborate in
high school
that he would casually use the word all
the time
i [ __ ] up so there's like i just
imagine insider
reporters calling going through the
yearbook hi did james that might have
literally been what they did
that at the time that this all happened
he was only 18 so he was
he had just graduated from high school
so it kind of makes like
you know if you're trying to corroborate
something like that who do you else you
reach out to but people that knew him in
in high school everyone's like oh yeah
they're like oh yeah
that guy she also claims james would
walk around the house naked
uh weinstein vibes freak
pretty weird um and if you think that's
bad everything she said
you know what's funny is james felt the
need to go to twitter
for literally no reason to defend
himself against this lawsuit
i was like james if you think that's bad
imagine
you should hear what other people are
saying about you who care who cares
about being a shitty employee
you sexed minors yeah i'm sorry
however watch how upset he is it's like
bro you sexed minors who cares
hi everyone i'm being accused of being a
bad employee you sexed minors bro
employer yeah employer it's like i'm
sorry stop you're [ __ ]
he's literally i feel like he's just
trying to divert attention
away because he's like here's this thing
i did that's not nearly as bad
constantly trying to portray himself as
the victim and that's what he's doing
here too
maybe if those little boys weren't so
cute
that's a line from a movie i think i'm
not physically attracted to
older guys right
it's from a chapel stand up okay thank
you i knew that i wasn't the architect
of that joke and i didn't want people to
get angry
get mad at chappelle not me
i hope you guys are all having a
beautiful i hope he's all whispering
he's in quiet mode i gotta use the
bathroom
okay should i wait for you no okay
you guys notice he's in quiet mode four
days so you know he's serious
the answer is
knowledge thank you wow good job zach
no but the real answer is um
pictures of uh
little you know here in my garage
males under the age of consent oh i am
being
cornered and have to make yeah another
public statement
i know people are sick of these i don't
blame you i'm not even going to bother
right now who cares about the lawsuit
you sexed miners you know what i'm
saying
and the lawsuit i mean i did anybody on
the crew know that this lawsuit was
happening
no idea like this this
brought attention to it like nobody was
talking about this
nobody cared about this lawsuit not and
not saying that people shouldn't care
because i mean
yeah compared to the sexting miners
thing it seems
relatively mild but it's still [ __ ] up
like dude what the allegations are in
this lawsuit
but why pay attention to it like nobody
it was under everybody's radar
i think james has this thing of like i
am a serial victim who is always being
blamed
and this is this feeds into the
narrative he's trying to paint
is that he's just this perpetual victim
that everyone's taking shots at
and it he in a way trying to deal
de-legitimize the sexting thing
because it's like here i am the victim
again
but i mean not to diminish that girl's
suffering but like this is like
jaywalking compared to the other [ __ ]
he's done
i mean that does diminish it a little
bit right
well well i mean because it is still bad
i mean
and i don't think we covered when we
talked about what happened but the
the the wrongful termination part of it
was that she was getting
they were getting their nails done
together because this girl from the way
she describes it was
basically his his servant in
every aspect of his life in addition to
being his producer
and they were getting their nails done
and the fumes from the nails
at the salon uh made her faint and she
fell on the ground and knocked her head
on the tile so hard she got a concussion
and so she was out of work for a week
and yeah wow that's [ __ ] up
that's so that's that's the wrongful
termination part and yeah i mean
it's really [ __ ] up yeah and the way
that she
describes the relationship i mean she
was
doing everything for him in the period
of time that he
blew up i mean he was already relatively
big youtuber but
it was the time that he exponentially
grew in the six months that she worked
for him
he went from like 2 million to like 9
million subs on youtube so this was like
his renaissance
that she was like doing everything and
then she missed a week of work
for getting injured doing something with
him and see ya
that's cold-blooded yeah that sounds
really wrong wow sister snapped that's
what he said when she painted it worse
than everything else i heard because i
kept hearing about this yeah i didn't
hear about it
and whatever but that is way worse yeah
that's horrible that
that's the wrongful termination aspect
but then there's also
she he she was working 80 plus hours a
week he never paid overtime
yada yada yada there there was well
that's a whole slew of things
that's all like he said she said this
and that i was like you know whatever
but it's like the lawyer said it depends
on the what the relationship was like
and how it was set up i mean
not every like you can work
in a way that is not hourly based
whatever the whatever look the details
of that old nitty-gritty wasn't it's
like well
only they know the truth about that but
like the story of her
passing out and being like oh [ __ ] her
snap and stepping over her corpse on the
way out
to hire someone new that's how i imagine
it
she's passed out on the floor he's like
oh sister schnapped and
walks out over her body
i need to leave my own news what abe i
said he's like can you shave my butt
real quick i need to leak my own nude
you know what happened he probably
farted in her [ __ ] face and she
fainted
easy and he's like just your snap that's
terrible
no the the butt shaving was actually it
was specifically for the infamous uh
coachella
right appearance yeah so that's evidence
that she shaved his ass
because i saw his bare ass and she
shaved it you know what i mean
oh yeah yeah yeah we're gonna say
something like rudely interrupt video
i'm gonna say
that everything together is painting
such a bad
character on oh yeah when james charles
did
bro can't even keep the people around
him
you know his friends hate him his
employees hate him yeah
he's sexting minors he's threatening
people in dms
dude that is so true dude needs therapy
and uh
and he needs to like move to tibet and
become a monk i feel like that's his
only salvation
that's his only way to do salvation
he needs to go live in an orange robe
and like
eat vegan for his life
you know you still get up to shenanigans
at the at the monastery though
you'll be like peeking up people's like
robes and [ __ ] oh my god
this is a little stupid i bet you the
monks would even kick his ass out
they'd be like listen james we're all
about peace and love here but you got
you gotta leave you're making us all
very uncomfortable
let's get glam
okay so that's james oh he posted this
video which is like again
it's like bruh yeah
he he gets real quiet though hello
everybody
james here i hope you guys are all
having a beautiful day afternoon at
night
i mean 50 000 likes so people are buying
this i guess i hope you're doing well as
well
you wouldn't like it unless you were
supporting him right i mean for the most
vast majority of people
right yeah i mean he's got 10 million
followers though so i mean
of course there's going to be lots but
still support them
damn that's amazing let the conversation
begin
right um don't worry this is not my
return
to social media but unfortunately i am
logging in today because i feel like
that kind of is though another public
statement it is
people are sick of these i don't blame
you i'm not even gonna bother writing
out like a whole notes out thing today
i'm just gonna hit record and start
talking to you guys one on one because
it's so capable
so legit so unrehearsed
um as you guys know for the past couple
of weeks i have obviously been offline
i've been taking time away shut the [ __ ]
up
freak hit him
you're a sex criminal just [ __ ] go to
tibet
sell all your earthly belongings and
move to the bed dude that's the only
salvation for you at this point
all right it's time for the grand finale
oh man
yeah let's just do the grand finale this
is important
so as i was explaining craft mayonnaise
has thrown down the gauntlet
and as you know zack our resident sachs
the sound lad
is a connoisseur of mayonnaise
look at that yes sir look at that look
at his background here let me show you
first of all they put out this co this
contest they said
prove your love to win the next craft
mayo endorsement here's their video
do you think they're going to claim me
can you imagine that'd be pretty [ __ ]
up
i'd be like [ __ ] you crap you know what
i'm not going to show their dumb video
because
they probably are going to claim me he's
eating mayo straight out of the jar
who i remember somebody doing that at a
real game is this him or is this like a
reenactment
straight out of the jaw who is this guy
okay so there was some legend in the
audience at a game
eating mayo at the jar yeah and everyone
games attended picked up a spoon i just
knew
dude that was awesome that was the best
thing ever look at this
legend so anyway they say all right well
you know here's one hero but where's the
next hero hungrier than ever
do you have what it takes to win the
next may endorsement
prove it so they say prove it
hashtag craft mayo dorsment
hashtag contest i love contests like oh
yeah the only content in the world yeah
i think craft mail endorsement is
specific enough
hashtag
make sure to include a hashtag uh
salami sandwich anyway
so for a chance to win follow so
this is basically for you now dan do we
follow real craft mayo
i sure did i followed it on the podcast
account and we have to post a video do
we have the full video on to
on there or do we haven't posted it yet
but it's okay
here's what i want to do then i want to
watch it on
our twitter so that everybody can get
engaged
oh i see uh so you love love you had it
queued up so if you could uh be so kind
as to
post on the podcast twitter podcast
twitter
at the h3 podcast we follow
realcraftmayo
and we are about to enter our submission
and remember to use the hashtag now love
remember to use the hashtag
we pre-made the message in the the and
don't forget
contest yep hashtag contest is in there
and did you did you include food
uh no no food we did uh include i think
it's like
hashtag zach the mayo man or something
no don't do that that one's confusing no
it's not
what okay fine i just want to make sure
like because we got food as long as it's
got their hashtags
it qualifies egg salad hashtag egg salad
i know that's good with mayonnaise
uh yeah okay okay just put so anyway
yo be sure to submit by 5 14. that's
tomorrow
right holy [ __ ] we're doing it right now
so they say eight finalists will be
nominated via
instagram or twitter direct message
where does it say you won ten thousand
dollars
there's like a whole rules page and then
i think in the video itself they
said it too but not just ten thousand
dollars the winner gets put on a
billboard in
they say your hometown which for zach is
la so
dude that's tricky imagine me on the
sunset
after you guys see the video we made i
don't see how zach doesn't win this
wait i'm trying to see where they sit
because they definitely said one two
okay so anyway
zach's gonna win 10 grand did you guys
post it
uh love give give me confirmation that
it's up
yep it's up it's up okay all right baby
this is it
make me the mayo man dude there's no way
after you guys see this
oh great there's already a clip of us
live on deaf noodles twitter
ethan klein response to triller lawsuit
being refiled against him
yeah whatever which is funny h3 podcast
drama okay zach this is how you feeling
zack
i am so hyped for this you have no idea
i'm so excited
i'm like [ __ ] carlos right now dude
here's the thumbnail
beautiful oh wow lots of engagement
already thank you guys
for supporting our young our good sweet
boy zach
you feeling you feeling confident you're
going to win this you're going to take
this home
i am the mailman i was born for this
yeah there's i there's no competition
man i don't think anyone's gonna move
mayonnaise like you do
if i'm being honest i mean come on like
what
what you guys are about to see is
[ __ ] game changing like
nothing you've ever seen in your life
all right all right
all right well without further ado
introducing
the real craft mayo man zack
[Music]
hi how you doing today my name is zach
lewis
also known as zach the soundline
beautiful day in southern california
today i'm going to show you why i am the
true mailman and why
i should win from craft the mayo
endorsement
you can see all the mayo things i've
done eating it raw i put
mayonnaise in my hair with the help of
big ed
dressed up as the joker i put mayonnaise
on my face
for a christmas special who else does
that today
is the ultimate challenge a bathtub
full of mayonnaise
[Music]
wow that was a dramatic and
now for the massive mayo movement we've
all been waiting for
yes you see that right it's a kiddie
pool full
of [ __ ] mayonnaise
craft mayonnaise that's all craft
managed man the finest mayonnaise in the
world may i add craft
mayonnaise which brand is it
number one brand craft mayonnaise baby
let's go
you know where to get it you know what
it is
high quality craft manic hear that baby
pour
oh yeah that looked real good
real craft man oh a little chaser
baby nice toe damn wicked feet what's up
dude
yo chill dog okay here we go all right
we're going in
into what the real craft mayonnaise
that's right
oh yeah
oh this feels nice
yo those are handfuls oh gosh
i'm the real mayo man okay real craft
mayo endorsement here you want some damn
good you sure
yeah i'm pretty sure no ela you want to
come shake my hand
thank you
yeah there it goes all right now that's
a superman
[Laughter]
you're my superman's eye oh that's sweet
got a sandwich in there
it's so gooey here it comes here it
comes give it a squeeze
[Laughter]
there we go there it comes
[Music]
oh yeah that's what i'm talking about
let's take another bite
from the real craft mayonnaise i'm
hungry actually
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah boy yeah
but let's go real craft mayonnaise
is that real crap man it's real crap
mayonnaise baby
love me
we got the power washer out
the mayo footsteps for me [ __ ] cold
stay safe trying to be gentle
gentle touch
for your consideration
craft mail endorsement contest
zach loves craft and hashtag um
potato salad i don't know
man how do we lose this
thanks for watching the greatest mayo
ever made exactly and what's your
favorite mayo brand
[ __ ] craft real mayonnaise man i
liked and retweeted it by the way let me
leave a comment
so love you're saying we have to do what
we have some kind of specific action we
need to take
or was that a b i'm sorry somebody said
there's something specific we have to do
what i mean i think we just said love
said you we got to tell people to
comment that we sent them on their
instagram and twitter oh we're supposed
to
say that we don't have to but okay
you want oh they'll find out
i thought there was some kind of rule
yeah let them know we sent you i mean
i'm pretty sure they'll see it
yeah the i think just the main thing was
just using their two
contest hashtags so so i'm going to
follow did you follow uh
the real craft on the instagram account
because that's part of the that ha the
podcast does yeah
yeah you guys all right cool yeah zach
don't worry we got you boy
what are you so how are you feeling i
mean tell me about the experience first
of all
how many tubs of mayo did we get how
much did we spend on mayonnaise
well dan very graciously went got costco
sizes of real craft mayonnaise there was
like 10 10. yeah they were gallon
bottles and i got 10
so that was 10 gallons how much how much
did we spend on mayonnaise
um you know it really wasn't actually
that bad it was probably like 80 bucks
or something okay 80 bucks for
mayonnaise
maybe a little more than that but yeah
it really wasn't and what was the fee
did you did your skin feel healthy and
rejuvenated
look look at my hair did it you're
glowing you know what that's actually
true your hair looks really good look at
my hair today it's like yeah
i wonder if they would take that
vertical of like mayo hair care product
like maybe it's a whole new vertical for
them i i mean
it's just you you want hair like this
you get yourself some real crap
mayonnaise
yeah that's what i'm saying there you go
did you get any mail like down your
pants or anything oh it wasn't like
crack it was everywhere
it was everywhere i took two showers
when i got home oh my god
my beard still kind of like it's in
there you know but it's cool if i you
know
but it doesn't bother you right because
you love it no i
am the mayo man i am the mayo man
yeah and this challenge is accepted
and i have to win this yeah i feel i'm
feeling confident
i don't i don't see how you could
possibly lose
yeah otherwise it's rigged as trump said
you know either you win or it's rigged
you're stealing it they'll probably give
it to mike
right i hear that guy shits his gym
shorts
well is there anything else you want to
say for their consideration before we uh
say goodbye and wish you all the best uh
i want to say that um i am the real
craft mayonnaise man
and um i've worked my whole life for
something like this and
first and foremost i have to thank you
ethan and ela for you know
helping me achieve my dreams of becoming
a male thank you
and dan and emma yesterday and a b
and love for all your support absolutely
i'm going to be the craft mayonnaise man
and it is going to be glorious are you
are you uh what does trisha say when you
like imagine something
manifest are you are you manifesting
right now absolutely
out hundred and [ __ ] 50 i'm
manifesting
the male man i'm manifesting for you
right now too
everybody manifest this
[Applause]
prove to the world that anything is
possible
that you can sit in the kiddie pool of
mayonnaise
and win ten thousand dollars i'm sorry
and that
that you could just be a young boy from
uh
a small suburb of los angeles and rise
to such greatness all right believe
we all believe and zach thank you for
for going through all that exactly do
you have any plans in case that you do
win the ten thousand dollars
you gonna buy bitcoin or ethereum
rollout or moon or
or are you gonna buy a rolex
well i was thinking about that but i
think i'm gonna have to be a little more
practical since like i am on my own
yeah you know there's that would be
[ __ ] cool but there's other
priorities
so what are you going to do with it
probably just put in the bank
yeah that's hard look at that
i heard you can get a hundred trillion
moon uh safe mode safe moon yeah
safe ones going to the moon baby
i heard safe moon's uh old news now
actually now it's a
galaxy or something or real i don't know
it was just another one of those
shitty wait did they really make a new
coin called safe galaxy
i i think that's what it was called holy
[ __ ] galaxy
there's a sucker born every [ __ ]
second you know that saying there it is
what's the safe galaxy worth uh let's
see save galaxy
well zach we found a good investment
opportunity for you
i just bought 39 million shares of safe
money
is worth 0.0000053
dude that means that just means you're
getting on the ground floor
right look at this mayo festing
oh mayo festing instead of manifesting
mayo oh that's good
from the chat that's good shout out to
the chat for that one
yeah we're mail festing yes love it
they're gonna have have they if they
haven't even already respond it's rigged
like let me look at the stats on this
here i retweeted it i liked it
people have been going crazy it already
has 2 000 likes
420 retweets i mean this is it
this is a baby you know what let's look
at the other contestants i'm curious
what the
competition is let's see um i think
maybe we shouldn't it's just some people
minding their own business
right i'm just oh you looked at it
already i just don't wanna we don't
wanna we don't wanna stick the uh
the mob on yeah right that's a good
point i don't wanna do that either
all the foot soldiers who we love and
are very loyal we don't need them going
after
no yeah yeah yeah we'll let zach's going
to win on his own merits we don't need
to we don't need to interfere with it
i'm just genuinely curious but you're
right i shouldn't uh
i shouldn't uh solely the the integrity
of this content
i love your enthusiasm man well i'm
starving i'm gonna go eat tomato myself
oh yeah i don't know what ever eating
mayo again after yesterday
next time you guys see us that's
actually not true because
friend it's weird we're keeping
frenemies frenemies will continue to be
brought to you from the basement uh due
to some logistical
concerns with uh with trisha and
everything um
but yeah theoretically the next uh
off the rails and or uh after dark will
be from the new studio
i'm gonna have to do it assuming
everything goes smooth i mean
fingers crossed you got it you guys got
it i believe in you
if we if you if we're back in the
basement uh next week you know that uh
something uh didn't quite go according
to plan this weekend that being said off
the rails might be canceled after what i
know
right yeah i was gonna say we i'm gonna
need like a lawyer with me when i do off
the rails it's hilarious
i'm so off the rails i need a lawyer
with me the whole time emily becomes a
new uh co-host
wrangler is it really off the rails if i
have a lawyer next to me
it's kind of a funny gag though where
they always whispering in my ear like
oh i i i take that statement back that
statement was uh
erroneously stated right or or the
episode would just be all cut up like
jump cuts because we cut
crazy [ __ ] out then jake ball said
and then well anyway in other news
off the rails is trouble
got your hat well gotcha
wait play this guy where's the crying
one so can you express
so back to safe galaxy for you zach can
you express it's point
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero four nine four that seems like um
gosh ten how what is that like one
millionth of one cent
yeah it's going to the moon baby the gas
money baby
and it's money baby so hypothetically
speaking if i
put in let's say ten thousand dollars
how much safe galaxy can i get
oh jesus cause it's going to the galaxy
baby
[ __ ] [ __ ] lot
oh man the uh i mean the market cap on
it
says 48 million 40
million unbelievable yeah but also low
because like safe moon has like billions
in market caps
yeah for a crypto that's actually low
but that does mean that 48 million
dollars worth of
money has been happening suckers have
been uh separated from their money
yeah your investment will infinitely
grow
say what maybe i said infinitely uh grow
and safeguard right just like
going to the moon just like blanks uh
intelligence
uh oh right right the value of safe
galaxy can only be compared to
phase blanks uh iq number
dan's crunching numbers in his head yeah
it's easy
500 millionths of a cent
whoa yo you guys can get on the i think
i might i might have [ __ ] it up by one
decimal but
at that at that low of a number five you
guys been on the ground floor of galaxy
moon galaxy safe safeguards
galaxy it's only one 500 millionth of a
penny you guys
yeah something like that yeah so what
did you say well you said like ten
thousand dollars worth that would be
dude that's like more stars in the
observable universe
you need like a super computer to crunch
that number
oh man look at shredder all right guys
this is a long one eh we've been going
for a while yes we've been going for
quite a while here was a great episode i
had a lot of fun
how'd you what'd you guys think you had
fun today did i say too much
that's for you and your lawyer to
discuss it this afternoon
are you going to yell at me when we get
off there no
[Laughter]
sure ed you're so beautiful i love you
i love you so much
all right well it's thursday baby you
guys all deserve the weekend
yeah now weekend for us this weekend
shout out to the families
you guys enjoy your weekend you deserve
it
thanks it's i know you're being genuine
but it doesn't sound like it but i know
you are being
i know i am i am i don't want to say it
too much i didn't want to accidentally
say too much info that's why but yeah
no i know you're being genuine though
and thank you baby for saying that
i hope this doesn't make you sound like
a douche [ __ ] you zack
[Laughter]
oh man i can't wait to sit next to zach
i haven't sat next to the guy since i
worked for you guys
you haven't seen that we're all gonna be
in the same room yeah
don't push that button except for poor
love over in sweden but
you know what's gonna be weird soon
we're going to be able to see people
without a mask again
oh did i say about the cdc thing i don't
think so they just before the show went
live cdc put out a new guideline saying
if you've been vaccinated
you can be around you can now wear um
not wear masks
indoors in and outdoors
no match fascinated cdc let's go
baby get that shot do you have your
passports
did you get yours making me
uncomfortable
tucker tuck the dick carlson all right
real quick i just i think you'll find
this amusing i saw a thing that
the latest in the conspiracy world is
that some
you know anti-vaxxer conspiracy theorist
type people apparently now
think that people that are vaccinated uh
are breathing out some sort of harmful
particles oh i think i heard that
and that they should wear masks to
protect themselves
wait that's got to be i can't troll i
kind of had the same thought that that's
something but like apparently that is
like going around
the best book troll ever
one of the fights with my cousins right
there are you serious
really i thought i thought he was
trolling me i'm like there's no [ __ ]
way you're serious wait so he believes
he needs to wear a mask to protect
himself from our respiratory
droplets or whatever he was saying that
he was
understanding actual illness oh my god
this sounds like aeronautic go ahead and
say the source was more reputable
than what we get on the news but you're
vacated how come he shared a car with
you
it was just an awkward situation i don't
know i don't know yeah
oh yeah yeah wow call me your update
oh we have a mayo update yep
oh craft like the tweet okay we have a
mayo update breaking news
we have a breaking announcement they
liked it
let's [ __ ] wait what is this live
caption
huh it's like sorry that's
just says hi how are you doing is that
just someone messaging you love
no no yeah don't worry about it
i demand to know what this is it's
twitter has a captioning thing he has
the captions on that's that's the
captions of the video oh okay i
understand
sorry facebook faith blanks never claim
to be smart
[Laughter]
oh my god it's on their likes okay so we
have an official like oh from craft mail
all right this is a huge
developer this is a huge
step forward we are mail festing this
i am very excited i'm thrilled to
announce
whoa we've been acknowledged and hack
your famous
dude craft twitter is blowing up right
now
this is what i'm talking about baby yo
this is amazing
we've we mayo fested it or whatever zach
left his house and he's like watch how
high i'll fly
[Music]
that's right i'm the mayo man that's
right baby
here let me go to crap while i'm here on
twitter yeah this
um i saw shake shack is training and it
seems like
because this uh in new york city they
said locations will add free
fries to your meal in may if you show
your vax card
really wow
that's kind of epic that'll get that's
going to motivate more people to get
vaccinated than like
uh dr fauci did somebody say fruit
french fries
yeah you know what you can put on those
french fries
real craft mayonnaise
[Music]
[Applause]
yo um wow they really liked the tweet
they really liked it you guys oh my god
i mean come on this is this is the most
attention their contest is gonna get
who's coming to math who's coming to
real craft mayo on twitter
i have no reason in my life to interact
with
mayonnaise on twitter i know that is
just not something that would ever
happen
yet here we are here we are this is huge
you guys
this is huge yeah this is exciting
all right well we'll have a lot of
exciting news to report
well guys i guess that's about it
anything else y'all want to add
anyone want to add anything before we
sign off uh
free fries i deserve that i deserve that
it's [ __ ] thursday
yo can we get some tasty food because
it's kind of like the
we're having like so hungry i'm starving
i'm starving too i'm so hungry
what do you want to eat let's discuss
food people like when we do this
[Music]
shake shack all right let's end this now
should we drive there or order
he wants to drive defense uh i don't
think we can drive
yeah oh also we have a call i do have i
have another little programming note did
you want to talk about
the podcast you're gonna be a guest on
next week
uh shh i don't know what's gonna air
those guys like can episodes for like oh
they like pre-record a shitload of
episodes
okay but yeah i'm doing uh
you could say well i'm just saying i
don't know what it's going to happen
that's a good point no i forgot that
they
yeah it might not i'm doing a podcast
with my friends bert kreischer and tom
segura but i don't know when it will air
recording it next week because those
[ __ ] can episodes like it's
like it's pringles nice i don't know how
people do that
it's called smart and yeah i think they
like block
intellect bro it's called it's called
intellect my dude
um there's a donation i think we should
read
go ahead what you got y'all y'all should
see
if a magnet sticks to your vaccination
site if it does you all been chipped
[Laughter]
oh man that's true that's a good
science experiment
i don't have any magnets on hand
that's too much fun i hate to say
goodbye but uh all things
all things uh good must come to an end
there's been another fantastic
episode of after dark i thank you all so
much for being here
you know and let's just say
i don't want to blow the war horn but
wow just saying the calls of battle
are nowhere to be found are not echoing
through the hills yet
oh oh go ahead and just give them a
sneak peek
i'm ready to go to work don't do it oh
[ __ ]
he's got a sword in him oh wow sword i
don't want to kill anyone a.b
for protection oh i say okay he's your
short
he is your sword should there be like
chiller be like new complaint we were
threatened
with violence physical violence from uh
av
zach play the horn all right kill switch
that was actually me that was i'll play
the horn sneaking that in
no i'm not saying i'm blowing this
but let's just say
wow that is powerful that's a really
powerful world
i'm getting shivers just hearing it and
the stream
okay i love you bill i'm sorry all right
guys we will see you next week and until
then it's friday baby
it's thursday on friday baby
yeah baby bye-bye i deserve shake shack
bye-bye
gaps with all the guests you'll see the
best podcasts in the world take it from
me jc
over j hp baby we podcast now
you're watching three three three three
three you're watching eight to the three
three three three
you're watching h to the three three
three three you're watching h to the
three
three three three my drinks are made out
of
you